[Music]
okay
perfect
[Music]
all right what's up everybody welcome
back to the dope as usual podcast my
name is Thomas dobiziola whatever you
want to call me I am with Marty O'Neill
what's up what's up what up this is the
double usual podcast we're here to talk
about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between today we
I'm excited I I know this person very
well so this is going to be a fun
episode introducing Adam Mill what's up
ill sorry I [__] said I rolled that
[__] like ours what's up man it's all
right dude it happens uh I'm chilling
Dad how you doing just you know Staying
High chilling hang out this is not Russ
for everyone out there thinking this is
Russ it's not Russ he looks like me by
the way I don't look like restaurants I
had to explain who Russ is to Marty
because he's listening to music okay
that's past 2008 right yeah so yeah not
Russ for everyone out there thinking
that it's him in the thumbnail it's
[__] not no no no no no no he uh you
know he we dressed to see he dresses
like me We dressed the he dresses he
dresses like I'm older you know what I'm
saying I've been wearing the clothes a
little bit longer but look he's your
essence is what you're saying bro bro I
know him or her he posted a picture yeah
and I went
oh that's Adam I actually had to take a
second ago
oh [__] you really do look identical to
this [__] dude my girl actually
made a little side-by-side post it was
like that's the one I was talking about
six pictures and those were me some are
him I had to really look yeah because
he's wearing the same glasses right now
too he works yeah it's kind of shocking
yeah he got into a club or some [__]
like yeah yeah oh yeah I'll take it
though yeah you probably could yeah yeah
of course especially at night with a
hoodie on I've had people come up to me
like
work and then they're like oh [__]
you're not pressed I'm like oh man
whatever Jewish kid I'm just a Jewish
kid from the valley
yo real quick
you are heavily religious right your
whole family like you grew up into the
[__] uh there were moments sure we
were a little Orthodox and I was
practicing Judaism a lot yes pretty much
fell in keeping Shabbat going to the
temple every weekend yeah all that wild
because my grandma was she was her whole
family was Jewish but my they married
the cat and they got cut off right but
my grandma Dolores for
what I was about six and she tried to do
the whole like in I don't even know what
to call it she was being like Hebrew and
[__] she brought out this candles with
the seven [__] things for Hanukkah
for Hanukkah she was going hard and then
I mean me and my sister were dicks
Simpsons and that's what we grew up on
yeah so my grandma started speaking and
I said like
and then me and my sister started making
fun of her and then she like closed the
[__] put in a box never [__] doing it
again never even spoke about it again
you broke her heart she we broke her
[__] heart yeah I felt bad she's
trying to get you involved with your
roots dude you know but it's like
this side is the Jewish and then here's
the brown side that's my whole life it's
like my grandma's like all right we'll
just forget about these roots yeah put
it in a box let's just watch this have
you down to 23 of me yet or like uh no
to see if you're I feel like if I give
that away they're like hey they're just
gonna
make another me or something oh my God I
don't know man I'm always curious
where my family is DNA to a random
stranger
please please it's like yo Netflix
Oh damn it's a whole [__] show now
that's [__] [__] not for real but
no I haven't done Twitter but you have a
cell phone on you right yeah and know
where you're at and they listen to
everything
how many times Marty where I talk about
something go we know you're listening
it's okay I do it a lot it's okay
all the time I hope you got that yeah I
know you guys heard that and then boom
type in the first thing on YouTube
sometimes though if I'm really into
something or I want to shop I'll start
talking about that yeah and then I'll
get the advertisements for you and I'll
be like hell yeah they filtered for me
yeah when I type in YouTube on my TV I
go uh and I say Bill Burr getting mad
and Bing I type in B and that's the
first yeah see that's convenience it
helps they're going to listen anyways
Total Recall I wish I wish my brain had
like a Google search so I could like
Google search my own like what's my
favorite movie what's my favorite color
it's called your memory bro I don't have
that
I don't know
I just want Google to remind me what the
[__] people's brain is smooth this
shit's got no memories retained yeah
it's like I feel like I [__]
sometimes too with the memory but you
know it's just what do you mean like you
can't remember [__] bro what my girl
gets mad at me because I don't remember
[__] dude I used to do an event every
Sunday and have the second people come
back every week and I still don't know
who they are it's just like hey what's
up but I'm also seeing a hundred of you
that's different I understand that so
like there's certain moments where I'm
like bro I don't I'm sorry it's just
mush wow that sucks I'd be [__]
heated if I couldn't remember stuff yeah
well you know that's what makes you so
special dudes you've got a great memory
yeah
it's like Mentos that's why it's great
to like have people around you to remind
you of these moments you're like oh yeah
we do did do that and it's all it's like
a brand new moment again oh yeah so we
got into
a little bit where did you grow up the
valley wise where did you grow up go to
[__] middle school high school and
you said so uh yeah yeah so pre-teen
years I lived North Valle the North
Valley like uh the Granada Hills North
Ridge area Okay uh which is you know
like the earthquake [__] that's all I
know about North Hills exactly dude so
that's what happened in 1994 there was
the Northridge quake and we were living
like okay so if you really know the
valley there was this one part where um
Balboa and Rinaldi where the gas pipe
blew up and it melted the water line and
then there was like a flood and a fire
and it burned like six houses I was like
on that street and that's like Bill
Clinton wait I think Bill Clinton was
the president at the time he came ready
for you he came to our block and was
like because it was like a national
tragedy whatever and after that like my
parents took that as a sign like get the
[__] out of here we got to leave America
let's go back to our let's go back to
Israel like this is wait you moved away
yeah yeah I lived in Israel for a year
so so pre-teen years so like when I was
born I was born in the valley 818 say it
backwards baby Valley kid you already
know
backwards I get you yeah baby so like
preteen did all that and then the 94
Quicks happened and my face it's got a a
tragedy and goes let's go to another
country yeah well you know out there uh
there's no earthquake just just
religious conflict daily with like bombs
and just buses I'll take the earthquake
and tie ropes to all the trees and just
in case I fall into a crack [__] that
yeah so I was like uh I was just hitting
my double digits in age and we moved to
Israel and try to adjust over there new
language went to school became a citizen
everything and then it was just like you
know it was me and my siblings and my
parents and it was hard for us to adjust
to like all new language all new people
throwing up on Nickelodeon yeah
traditional they weren't like straight
up doing all the customs and stuff while
you were in America you were you guys
were just American no no no I mean my
parents uh my dad was uh was born in
Africa and my mom was born in Europe and
they met in the Army in Israel and then
when they decided to have a family they
wanted to come to the states to have
like a better opportunity for their kids
and then we were everything's good I
mean you know we've got a cool education
I learned a lot uh then the earthquake
happened they're like let's just go back
to Israel I guess trying to figure [__]
out you know so we moved there and then
was your house totaled uh we had like a
yellow tag on our house what's that mean
it means you can't it's it's not safe to
stay in you got green tagged yellow
tagged or red tag red tag is like
condemned don't go in it's dangerous
Yellow Tag is
there's some issues you could say but be
cautioned and then green is like you're
good so you're good dad what did you do
for work that he goes you know what [__]
this life let's move my dad was always a
hustler he was always able I think
that's where I got my [__] drive from
is just being with him at jobs seeing
him hustle he used to sell just you know
he worked at a gas station he had his
own gas station he worked in like
welding got like did custom gates for a
bunch of people he uh was doing fashion
he was trapping a bunch of fabrics back
in the late 1900s and now he's doing
jewelry now he's like you know what
jewelry is delaying everyone gets
jewelry there's always so uh he's doing
jewelry now that sounds cool [__] but he
was always able to adjust and adapt to
any circumstances and I think that's
where I got my like drive and hustle
from
um so we just moved there and we just
packed up a trailer and my dad's like I
got some ideas to bring to Israel you
can't drive there what do you mean uh we
like we like uh one of those big old
trailers like the [__] that you see
on ships like a 40-foot trailer and you
just put your whole life in there like
our car we brought a car over there we
brought like our whole bedroom sets like
our whole like imagine you just take
your whole house all you just put it in
the trailer and ship it to like another
country like we're starting over had you
done there before
oh yeah yeah I traveled often because I
have family over there so I traveled
often and um oh okay okay so it's not
like new [__] life well living is
different than vacation yeah for sure
like moving there like this is your
permanent residences here's a whole
different language a whole different
lifestyle as a kid like is it more is it
the same I mean you don't you don't I
mean did you have your life friends you
already had it like you have
relationships with kids you know you're
on the Block and then all of a sudden
you have to start all over so it's like
I'm the kid from America I'm the
English-speaking kid I'm the one that's
standing out more so you know there's
those kids out there that like the
bullies or whatever that want to like
[__] we try to [__] with you and you
have the cool kids that are accepting
and you just got to figure out you know
it's just being a kid dude we all deal
with that everywhere but I think in a
different country with a whole different
language and a whole different lifestyle
not knowing anything dude you ever learn
the language yeah yeah well my parents
spoke to me so I understood actually
learning like having an education in a
different language where they're
speaking to you in that language and
you're trying to learn you're like
like I was reading like I could read but
I could read like a [__] kindergarten
or a first grader you know like it's not
I'm not like at the level that my peers
were at so you just feel like the
special kid they make you feel like [__]
like the Mexican people did the Thomas
yeah you know like you yeah exactly it's
just like you don't know
ever you're the American you're not the
[__] real Israeli people do this yeah
but
people were cool they're like oh America
yeah let's
you're like well [__] you dog like this
is my school
you could be the cool kid from LA and
just be a president yeah I thought that
was a cool kid I mean I had one of those
bicycles that looked like a motorcycle
you remember those and you press the
buttons
I'd be like the cool kid on the [__]
block and then other kids were like man
[__] this fool coming from America
thinking I get it so you were there for
a year so we're there for a year and
then like you know just with school you
know my brother was I have an older
brother and a younger sister and it was
just like hard for us to adjust so my
parents were like let's just go back let
them do their education there and we
came back to it after a year later and
it was [__] hard for me again because
if we moved to a whole new neighborhood
in the valley I wasn't in the same area
so pre-teen I was North Valley then when
I came back as like my teenager years I
was in the South Valley
Encino like that area I became like a
[__] skateboarding Punk kid I was on
Ventura Boulevard skating working at
like a skate shop [__] all that [__]
nice yeah yeah when I came back so this
is like what like 98 late 1900s yeah the
late 1900s God it sounds so old when you
say it like that but it's true to us
yeah when you think of the late 1900s
what do you think I think of the 80s and
the 90s
grew up guys
regrets on my channel
I've never heard that before like that
the first thing I heard or thought of
was a guy in a white wig
wait nah bro
that's like 30 40 years ago now dude the
late night and we used to refer to that
like when we did the late 1800s and like
the 70s and 80s we were like oh the late
1800s we're there now dude we're in the
late 1900s bro that's a time frame that
y'all gotta sorry YouTube look if you
were born in the late 1900s shout out to
you baby you get it we had a different
life yeah it was fun yeah we had to we
actually went on the street
and played yeah but I got to be honest
now
I'd be inside too with all these crazy
guys video games and dope [__] and both
are shooting each other I've been
sitting inside too that's true I mean
you know it's different as like an adult
as a kid like playing on the street or
on the cul-de-sac or whatever like it's
like now like now we think of all the
realities I just don't want to get
stabbed by a tweaker riding a bike going
somewhere I got to be safe but as a kid
I never thought about the Tweakers until
the Tweakers were closed that's what I'm
saying I'm like oh let's get away I
think that's why they say ignorance is
bliss because the less you know the
happier you are so once you start
realizing [__] and that's why I think as
we get older in real life's life like
all these dreams we have and all these
things we thought of we're like man this
is never gonna happen I don't even want
to go outside
I want to be a Toys R Us kid dude I
don't want to grow up [__] I saw
somebody in a store the other day with
big plastic Toys R Us sign on a wall
like it was an old fire so [__] right
um all right all right so that's where
you grew up so you said yes
so yeah when I came back from it from
Israel I was like a little punkish I
became like a pumpkin I mean living in
Israel dude like it's different out
there you would go to the mall and there
would be like
because Army is mandatory once you
graduate high school you have to enlist
like it's part of being a citizen there
so like I'd go to the mall and there'd
be like teenagers with [__] AK-47s
and it's just chilling in their full
fatigue because they're still regular as
kids but it's mandatory so like life is
different out there it's they appreciate
a lot more because you never know when a
Rocket's gonna [__] come and hit your
town you don't know when you're on a bus
and it's going to blow up you don't know
when you're in a club and this is like
the late 1900s it's a lot it's not as
bad as it is now as it was then it's
still there's still conflict but
they have like a different appreciation
for life out there like they are like
it's always celebrated like if you're if
you're here you're celebrating life so
when I came back I just [__] there
was so much [__] so many rules I was
like man [__] this [__] I became a
little [__] [__] or skateboarded
[__] thought I was a [__] cool kid
would you start smoking weed Bar Mitzvah
13. yeah yeah yeah I'm a man now I'm
smoking
what is weed like in the Jewish culture
they're like older Jewish people smoke
weed I mean it's like anywhere some
people accept it some people don't I
think just the more with education
that's what I that's why I started doing
what I do is just educating people on
the benefits of cannabis uh more than
just [__] just doing it because I
mean cannabis helped me a lot when I
started maybe it wasn't just getting
high maybe it was like you know it was
preventative like make taking minerals
or vitamins like it just made me feel it
made me feel better it made me focus and
made me appreciate a lot more and I was
preaching it at a young age it was like
at 15 I started started like
reading books about and they was this
was hard to find in the late 1900s they
weren't stores selling clothes of weed
there wasn't like 13 at your little
party so 13 I spoke um my first time not
at the bar mitzvah but I was like yeah
that's what I was wondering like they're
sitting around [__] blowing down Jews
no this was back then there were no
torches back then dude it was just
[__] like zigzags and Randy's and
[__] Randy's what the [__] is it Randy
the wires remember the paper with the
wire in it so you could hold the wire as
a tour it was like that joint that had
like a built-in clip you ever had that I
don't even know what the [__] we're
talking about for everyone else papers
paper paper flat and there's a wire that
runs through the middle piece of metal
okay and you hold it and it look Loops
so when you roll your joint you just
hold it like that so the middle all the
way the [__] down and then you can hold
it at the end I have a box in my room
for a Nostalgia yeah
yeah but it was just that or like little
stream like little pipes you know or
plastic bongs and I at 13 I didn't have
a lot of access to it so I smoked it
when I can but 15 when I found out like
you know someone when I was able to get
it a lot easier uh it started becoming a
daily thing it was like a daily
consumption comparison uh so they knew
but I wasn't like I was a punk but I
wasn't a bad kid like I went to school I
got good grades I was working I never
asked them for money I never bugged them
I started working at a young age you
know I had that [__] Hustler
motivation for my father so I was
working at the swap meet I was working
out for my friends I was doing like
random [__] and I never had to ask my
parents for money good [__] so they
couldn't really say nothing discipline
me but they could just ask parents be
like yo I don't think this is like you
shouldn't be smoking but like I knew
like my dad would smoke like my dad what
like I knew because oh I didn't know
this so this is the thing like like my
dad was you know 70s 60s 70s I'm sure
all our parents so either you were with
the [__] movement or you weren't and
it's either one or the other there was
no like gray area so my dad had longer
hair I knew and when my dad came home
here's a little story look look here's a
little story dude look when my dad would
come home he would go straight to the
bathroom after work right and I'll be
like all right my dad's just [__]
going taking a [__] after work [__] cool
but it was like a unique fragrance I was
like I've never smelled [__] like this
before
my dad did that too but this smells like
it had like a more musty skunky like
kind of different fragrance and as I got
older and I knew what the fragrance I'm
like why does it smell like my dad's
[__] and I'm like this is [__] weed
my dad was smoking weed in the bathroom
while I was growing up this whole time I
always say it smells like X-Men in here
it smells like Super Mario Brothers in
here I say say that because my dad used
to hide in the [__] bathroom and when
I go in I'm like that smell what is that
smell yeah and it reminds me of hey go
play [__] real quick I'm gonna go to
the bathroom and I'd be playing X-Men
and Shinobi and you know we didn't smell
something when I got older I went smells
like my dad
dad my little brother was about six
we're walking through Santa Cruz
boardwalk and my brother hide everything
from him so recently yeah and this guy
walked by he was smoking a blunt and
Rocco just went
smells like Thomas's house yeah it felt
so bad like incense
[__] uh you smell [__] let's go play
games it's crazy how uh smells trigger
certain memories it's the quickest
Nostalgia to your brain to smell so I
was like crazy my dad's poop so your dad
will go in there smoke Bowl so that's
the first time you realize oh my God my
dad gets hot I was like oh [__] before
you smoked weed you found out that he's
smoking no no when I started smoking
weed and I knew what the smell was then
it triggered back to like oh that's what
my dad would do he's all 13.
I love that I guarantee there's a
million people out there right now going
yeah
yeah as a kid I was
extracurricular after school programs
you know I was a part of certain so they
couldn't really like don't do you're a
bad kid I was like they're like bro just
chill but like I started taking acid at
like 15. I started like rolling I was
doing like like candy flips I was eating
acid and taking ecstasy I was like a
teenager dude this is like bomb before
before the Insomniac Brave party this is
like
my brother was a DJ for I was about to
ask how much older he's four years older
than me so he was a DJ so like you know
he's like 18 19 DJing and I'm like a you
know 14 15. I'm like let me come to this
party dude and these are the parties or
like full moon tribe parties you know
it's like drive down this road when you
see the glow sticks make a right on that
[__] road this is before internet
before I like MapQuest anything you got
like a list it's like see the pile of
rocks that are stacked up make a left
there just go until you hear the
generator when you hear the generator
some Dwight shroop Direction bro this is
the middle of the desert parties used to
be dude before they were [__]
monetizing and oh that's great became a
business so I was there [__] the
youngest kid just taken everything
because my brother was straight edge he
wasn't doing [__] but I was the
brother's DJ that was a DJ's brother so
they're like oh look at this [__] I was
like
yeah he's like 17 you're 13 years old
but it wasn't that young no no he was
already 19 yeah he was like 18 19. yeah
yeah yeah yeah so you're 15 doing ads at
these parts sounds fun yeah it was so
like I started getting a different
perspective on life I started like you
know when you start doing
things that enhance your brain you start
seeing things in different angles
different perspectives like you start
having appreciation for things more you
start seeing things I say like in
reality like because we all we're always
just like straightforward but once you
start eating whatever it is mushrooms
DMT acid whatever I'm not saying to do
it but if you ever were to do it it just
opens up these other parts of your brain
that you never really have access to
yeah and I feel like it helps you it you
get like answers you want to watch
different levels in the game you want to
check those levels out if I want yeah
and you start you'll and then things
just like light bulbs start hitting you
you're like oh [__] okay I'm gonna
approach it differently this time so I
started so like I was a really good
student and then I realized like man
like what am I gonna why do I need to
know what a plus b equals c like what
the [__] do I need this [__] for in the
future like you know what I'm gonna do
I'm just gonna Vibe out I'm gonna be
cool to the teachers because they don't
they just this is their job they don't
really want to be in the classroom with
30 [__] kids eight hours a day you
don't want to be the one that annoys
them or [__] with them so I would like
come in I would
salute like hey good morning good
afternoon thank you bye-bye and they
would just be like like they were just
like talks too much that would be it but
I was a good student but that was it
though he just talks too much but they
would pass me because they're like this
kid has a brain he has Common Sense he
understands how the world Works he's not
going to be in trouble like let's just
[__] past so like I have asked all my
work like I don't [__] why do I need
to open up a book and fill in the blank
on questions dude that's just busy time
let me go out and like work on some [__]
you're literally just wasting my time
this is boring work like if I'm that
person cool I appreciate but I'm not the
person to like sit in a room all day and
do like the same tedious thing like I
can't do that I go crazy like that's why
I shout out all the [__] Growers out
there everyone who grows weed is this my
solo right here everyone who grows weed
look I don't give a [__] if it's one
plant or ten plants or 100 plants if
it's indoor outdoor basement closet
bedroom Warehouse whatever the [__] if
you've grown we thank you Doug because I
appreciate you I know how much time it
takes and how much patience it is I know
all the obstacles you guys deal with so
I appreciate y'all I I mean if you guys
were in growing weed I wouldn't be
smoking and we wouldn't have this
lifestyle that we're living right now
very true hey shout out to all of y'all
if you guys are beginners experts
rookies whatever dude I appreciate y'all
keep it up and I'm here to smoke your
weed if you uh if you're down and I'm
and I'm privileged enough to get it out
thank you guys oh this message has been
brought to you by Adam
I've helped Growers I've been in gardens
I'm sure you've seen them you see the
working and I'm not that person to stay
in a room and like sit there trim clone
[__] dead I would stop water weed if
I didn't if I had to grow my weed I
would just be a really healthy water
drinking [__] not smoke a weed
bored because I'm not gonna sit there
all day shoot my own food too while I'm
at it Jesus Christ oh [__] I'll grab my
plants they grow by themselves you have
to be there every day yeah that's if
they're work dude that's why they're
human it's like having a [__] a dog a
budget it's like having a bunch of
ladies do like on the girls and you know
if you want your lady to be happy you
got to spend time with her and you got
to pay attention to her and you gotta
feed her and you got to make her feel
good so you have a you have a thousand
of these ladies dude that you gotta like
water and make sure they're good you
gotta check their leaves make sure
they're [__] producing and then you
got the moms that you got to keep alive
and you know how we all love our moms so
you got to give them extra love it's
like a [__] whole process dude so
thank you yeah that's a great way to put
it nobody ever says that nobody ever
said that like I've never heard anybody
take that perspective yeah yeah it's
exactly what it is yeah I try to grow
once I forgot two days in and then he
died [__] I tried to ignore I've tried
outdoor by myself following books but
like we're busy dude like you do [__] oh
that's different the life I have right
now there's no way in the world I could
ever grow there's no time in the world
it's right now is why I'm sitting still
yeah it's crazy that's what I'm saying
so thank you guys yeah [__] yeah I try
to express that as much as I can I've
heard you feel I've heard you think the
Growers many times I don't think they
get enough love and respect as they
should get because a lot of us out here
are living this like I know there's a
lot of culture vultures out there that
are that are monetizing on this culture
that you know we're ashamed and talk
[__] about it and now they're out here
trying to make money and they don't even
know what a weed plant looks like you
know what I'm saying that just [__]
irks me
oh we'll get into that in a minute we'll
get into that [__] here in a minute
so yeah I started smoking out like
regularly at 15. look see he does camera
[__] he just came back and goes so what
to conclude that's our hardest thing
ever is to go what the [__] were we on
topic with where did this start you got
it you got it well you came back okay
transition Master let's go so Circle
back you got you got a job you're
smoking weed
you graduate high school yes right
you're done where do you go from there
because I know soon after you started
doing
your first step in entertainment which
was radio [__] yeah
how did that happen so right after high
school like I'm already kind of hooking
friends and family up because I have a
source for weed and
other ingredients this is like over 10
years so we're good now I could talk
about it so I would I was like you know
I became that person after smoking you
know at 15 respecting the plant learning
about it you just start meeting people
and you know the person you get it from
you meet where they get it from then you
meet and then all of a sudden you're
hanging out with the dude on the
Mountainside up north chilling you're
like [__] acres and I'm a [__]
white boy in the valley like what are we
gonna do
um so right when I graduate high school
I try Community College and I get a job
in the adult industry and in radio adult
industry porn I've no no I've never
heard you elaborate on this you just
told me I did some adult Industries yeah
what did you have to do so okay so just
put that in there so I worked she said
so I worked in the adult I'm from the
valley look Valley's known for pot and
Port you know what I'm saying [__] so
one of the people I used to get uh
someone like flour from was a family
member who worked in the adult industry
but he just did the warehouse of a
production company so anytime someone
ordered movies this is back when you had
you know we had a warehouse with the
shipping and it was VHS and DVDs were
just starting of porn stuff of yeah
films I worked for a major production
company so they had a bunch of movies
that they filmed they had their whole
their own like they had contract girls
contract directors Talent all this [__]
and I got a job out of high school in
the warehouse just doing like shipping
and inventory like you know count how
many box covers we have left or go get
fill up these orders here are all the
orders for the day so go get it so it'd
be like all right let me get [__]
anal gang bang six I need 15 of these
let me get [__] random hookups number
27 let me get 30 of these did you apply
for that job no no my cousin was my
cousin was there so I just kind of got
it they needed help in the warehouse I
was right out of high school with a
[__] young eager didn't give a [__] I
would get myself I would get my weed out
of it but it was like a legit job and
what happened is I'm doing inventory
[__] but I'm a young I'm eager I start
going in the offices you know like
talking to all the employees and they
discover I have a personality so they
give me a job in marketing and promotion
for this adult production company cool
so now instead of doing the inventory
and packing packaging and [__] now I'm
working with Talent working on the
images now all of a sudden like I'm
helping them with like AOL in Myspace
because this is way back then your
social media manager for porn stars this
is just like marketing and promotion but
at the same time I'm working for this
radio station uh case CBS radio klsx
97.1 in La it used to be Howard Stern in
the morning and uh then I went to Adam
Carolla in the morning you had Frosty
Heidi and Frank which are now Heidi and
Frank on the morning show 95.5 Tim
Conway Jr was on there Conway Whitman it
was like a whole bunch it was talk radio
so I was working for this radio station
and I was working at boring porn
discovered I had a personality they
moved me up I started doing office [__]
started working with Talent they casted
me in a couple movies no penetration I
wasn't doing it no penetration on film
but they gave me like speaking rules
these are actual like movies with
scripts and dialogues I'm sure you've
seen these feature films where it's like
an actual story a porn video with with a
feature like porn movies their actual
like
feature films where it's like a dialogue
script characters it's instead of like
all movies and TV shows we watch those
love scenes and they like simulate
they're like in bed and then they like
pan away or zoom into a fireplace or
they just switch scenes for feature
films in the adult industry instead of
zooming away into the fireplace they go
into the [__] [__] and then you
see the actors and they just start doing
whatever what did you do you came hey
so so sorry
that's what I think so there was one
movie that was I'm not gonna say the
titles because I don't need y'all Google
searching them but it was basically
taken back in like uh the Renaissance
time and I was like a drummer boy and
there was like so I was in the scene I
was like 18 dude I look like a [__]
young ass kid they needed someone on set
so I'm there [__] as a Drummer Boy on
this [__]
uh battle scene right saying I just sit
there it was just [__] scene boom got
a couple hundred bucks I'm like hell
yeah dude let's [__] run it then they
casted me with a [__] speaking role
for an alien abduction porno movie dude
we're sitting around a fireplace and
there's like all the actual porn stars
are sitting uh you know coupled up this
is so cool these 18 year old going
awesome oh
that's [__] funny dude sorry yeah
there was actually a scene at a sushi
restaurant where they wanted us to come
but we're like eating and they're
[__] like four tables away and I'm
like bro I'm not gonna eat this while
they're clapping cheese
like let me learn how to pretend yeah
yeah but they're like [__] 14 we're
like right where Marty's at I'm we're
over here like pretending we're a guests
at the restaurant I'm like bro what
there's a [__] big ass dick right
here
how am I supposed to eat some [__] right
now uh but there was like you know I had
speaking rules I was like the puck alien
abduction so the alien abduction one is
like we're around a fireplace and it's
like all these adult actors there and
they start coupling up and there's one
that was not coupling up so my character
was like trying to flirt with her and
she just denies me and I'm like I'm like
man [__] this [__] dude and I like walk
off smoking my weed because everyone
knew I smoked weeds I would like smoke
my weed and I have this little monologue
and then I get abducted by aliens I've
never got probe though but I got
abducted by aliens
bro but like hold on is this like a
movie like when PB Herman got caught in
the theater like one of those like a
movie so in here in the adult industry
in the porno World they have different
types of content that you film and some
of them are more just like you know ass
Masters and it's just focusing you have
all this weed all over it's all right
it's a [__] this weed bro we got a
lot of it
I'm sorry so like there's different like
you got ass Masters it's all like ass or
anal scenes and then you gotta act like
you monetized episode keep going we're
demonetized right now keep going
that's the point of the show I just knew
that was the point well anyways there's
all these different types of categories
I'm sure if you guys been on adult
websites there's categories for [__]
content so these films were actually you
don't just see the sex scenes there's
actual build up and dialogue and
characters and [__] to get involved with
so they use me as some of the characters
in the adult industry it's so funny that
I was in a porn um when she told me [__]
no then I got abducted by an alien
outside yeah that's insane like a little
monologue I was like man [__] do they
don't know what they missing dude
18 year old you out there in a porn
smoking a [__] pie getting upset at
these porn stars this is amazing I wish
I remembered my name in that that my
character but I had a whole story like
around the campfire we were telling
ghost stories I had to like talk about
the little monster that lives in the
refrigerator that opens and that turns
on and off the light when you open and
close it and I was looking for this
character forever dude it was like a
stupid character I had but I got paid a
couple bucks so I'm happy let's go
that's amazing
yeah what's up you need some dialogue we
out here so that was the first time you
got into any kind of entertainment I'd
love it it was fun so basically he was
doing the job that Robin Williams does
when Mrs Doubtfire he's just doing the
film you pack the boxes yeah you ship
yeah that was you then they caught you
[__] with the Raptor dinosaurs like
he has a personality give him his own
show yes yes so that's so at this so
while I'm working at the adult industry
I'm also working in radio and I'm doing
like promotions and and uh marketing I
was that dude that went on the streets
like you know when your radio station on
the street like the parking lot of the
whatever sponsor there is or but I got a
job right at 18 right out of high school
I worked in radio too I worked in radio
and porn dude my brother worked in radio
he got a gig there and I had a cousin
that worked in porn so I got a part-time
job at both while going to school so I
had an open schedule right so while I'm
in college dude I'm like paying money to
learn how to make money but I'm already
over here learning like getting paid
while I'm learning like the trade I'm
like in the trade I'm like in the adult
industry I'm in radio I'm like why the
[__] am I paying to learn when I'm
already getting paid I'm getting like
six eight paychecks a month doing this
[__] like I appreciate you education
I've met some cool people but well I'm
focusing on on a career this is like you
know 19 years old like [__] it I'm doing
this [__] so I've been pouring for a
couple years I'm in radio for a couple
years
the adult industry is very interesting
there's a lot of interesting characters
in there like I started looking at the
older Generations I've been in there for
a couple years I'm like yo this is cool
but like I don't know if this is a
forever thing and while I was at there
like my manager at the time he left and
then my manager be the general manager
became my immediate manager and he was
already like kind of iffy with me due to
like me being young and and all the
adult entertainers are like attracting
to me because I'm like the new young kid
in the office and I'm helping them with
their like
images and whatever the [__] I was doing
22.50 said legal [__] whatever bro
although and then so
he got upset
I was like whatever I left the adult
industry and I focused full-time in
radio
yo what's up guys welcome to the
mid-roll ad read this is one of our
sponsors FanDuel guys it's Wild Card
Weekend it's finally here football's
back the next four to five weeks is
gonna determine everything and if I have
to pick I don't know how but I feel like
the Raiders are gonna squeak by and I
know the bills are going to win let's go
all right all right the bills are gonna
win all right putting it out there so if
you're interested in this at all now is
the perfect time to take advantage of
FanDuel right now for all new customers
that sign up FanDuel Sportsbook is doing
30 to 1 odds the second you make a
deposit that means if you bet five
dollars you can win a hundred and fifty
dollars off that bet so remember Go
download FanDuel Sportsbook app use code
dope as usual when you sign up remember
you're never gonna have to chase FanDuel
this is not a bookie you don't have to
go chase this person down for your money
it goes right to your account in as
little as two hours all right you get
paid that day also if you already have
FanDuel and you're already a betting
person remember that all you do is have
a friend sign up they get 50 credit you
get 50 credit and a little disclaimer
guys please make sure you're in a
betting state it has every state listed
on the FanDuel app so download it make
sure you're legal to bet and remember
you have to verify that you're 21 you're
not going to be a 16 year old kid trying
to scam not going to work you're going
to have to verify your age so it's
really cool to us guys please help us
out download the app use code dope as
usual have a dope best day
hey what's up guys just want to take a
quick moment to talk about one of our
sponsors this is brought to you by
betterhelp Marty and I took on this
sponsor because there's people out there
that have no one to talk to that watch
our stuff maybe this can help them out
in the age of Zoom calls and everybody
being at home why can't a therapist be a
virtual call now you can go on
betterhelp.com and actually talk to a
licensed therapist not just somebody hey
you have eight people today no they
match you so right now if you go to
betterhelp.com forward slash dope that's
10 off your first month of treatment so
if there's something holding you back
guys and you need to talk about it some
people just don't have that person to
turn to I understand when I got kicked
down I had to move to Oregon I had
nobody to talk to my dad I was mad at my
dad I had to move out there he forced me
out there sometimes no matter what age
you are sometimes if you're 50 if you're
16 we all need an outlet we all need to
vent and if you don't have that now you
can do it without anybody in your family
having to know about it anybody in your
dorm or anybody at work nobody has to
know that you're doing online therapy
sessions it's not something to be
embarrassed about but the main cause of
people not getting help is embarrassment
so no more guys go to betterhelp.com
forward slash dope like I said that's 10
off your first month of treatment you
might as well try it out if this is
something that actually interests you if
you even looked at the screen a little
harder anything I said this could be for
you
and I was like this is what I'm gonna do
dude and I got a job at Radio uh at 18
and I don't know if you're familiar with
97.1 but the demographic was like 18 to
45 year old males and a lot of the
events were at like strip clubs the
Playboy Mansion bars so you're the kid
with the microphone at all these places
I'm like the 18 year old kid inside
these [__] bars and it's inside these
strip clubs because I'm working and I'm
there for the event just doing
promotions so like right out of high
school I'm getting these [__] gigs
I'm learning how to
entertain a crowd I'm and the biggest
value I learned working in radio is is
this part exactly is being on the street
is I learned from the account Executives
what they wanted me to execute to keep
their clients happy and while I'm at the
events I'm with the clients and they're
telling me what they expect and how they
can be happy so I'm here taking in the
sales team and the clients team and I'm
trying to make them both happy and
that's how I learned to monetize on life
and turning my passion into a paycheck
because in 2009 when the radio flipped
format and I was like host to HD radio I
was doing all the street [__] I was part
of the shows they had me on certain
segments we did this for a while yeah it
was like a decade in radio oh [__] yeah
and it was like I was involved I was
like they had me featured on a couple
shows I did some theme songs when I
thought I was a rapper they had me uh
they were like on the street segments
you know like where you ask people on
the street like they would have
questions of the week so I was doing
that and when they flipped formats to
like a top 40 station where their
demographic became
17 year old females they're like yo we
love you you're great but
we can't use you right now and then
that's that was 2009 and that's when
podcasting kind of just started so
that's when I started my podcast dude
the podcast in 2009 podcast when we
asked people for names they like
podcasts came up so many times already
well not even not that it's it's already
been done bro everyone does that now
anyone who thinks they have a podcast
about the podcast I think they're
original bro
and I knew you had it and I couldn't
even own it because trans High
Corporation owned it who's that High
Times they own podcasts but I was
working with like so once I started my
podcast first it started as the Adam
mcadosha show and in 2009 2009 it was
Adam mcadocious but I learned quickly
that Adam nacogdocious is horrible for
SEO search and optimization no one knows
how to spell it no no one knows how to
find it you type in added they spelled
it 20 different ways so I was like you
know what podcast Adam ill let's use my
real name [__] it let's get rid of this
nickname they call me Macadocious
because I turn blunts into roaches I'm
sure you heard that because of Mac Dre
R.I.P maybe yeah uh so so uh uh they
call Adam acadocious that's how I got it
from the whole one of my boys was like
super in a Metro how funny is that you
got your name from Macarena that's how I
got my name wait what uh but I don't use
that because SEO dude the [__] is hard
as [__] so uh
yeah so I just started the podcast and I
just changed it to uh the getting
Highway show dude so let's take
everybody on this little step 2009
podcast this is pre Instagram this is
pre people smoking weed on YouTube this
is my space day this is AOL
transitioning to Myspace so you're
sitting here doing what on the show this
is ASL to
posting that you're what you actually
look like what was I doing on the
podcast so as a sex locations oh my God
I remember that hey people you should
say that in chat rooms I was like
[__] 10. like what the [__] as we
could have swiped left you know in the
late 1900s
it was I was like [__] eight years
old yeah yes I'll do that's how you
found out who was in your neighborhood
if they're your age and then you dealt
with a lot of predators because people
were looking for kids
this is real life
[__] there's a whole show about it I
think Christine hosted it
so so hold on podcast what are you doing
on this show so okay so not only did I
do a podcast so after so 2009 when I'm
done with radio and I thought this was
gonna be my [__] like I kind of had a
little slump I started like I made a
resume and like turned in job
applications to like middle of the mall
stores and [__] I'm like what am I
[__] gonna do and then
radio yeah because there was like it's
like what's going on but then podcasting
became a thing and um I started
podcasting but at the same time I was
butt tending because that was already
smoking weed so the first shop I
bartended at was called FWC it was in
Tujunga on Foothill Boulevard all right
I became a bartender 2009.
um that was the same time I started
podcasting but what I learned when I was
butt tending is no one knew what the
[__] they were looking for when they
came into a dispensary you usually
they're used to whatever they get in a
parking lot or whatever their hookup
gets them they're like oh this is where
I got this week uh I'll roll up another
one
thank you that takes me 30 seconds we're
good thank you I got some fancy [__]
one-hitters over here let's go do you
want to join Marty [__] no I got I got
a couple okay
yeah these things are sick right God
damn yeah so I started butt tending dude
like so when I left radio so I was known
as the station pot head I would hook
people I would be that guy on Christmas
time that walks around with the stuck
stock uh stocking full of just like gram
bags and I'll go to all the employees
there that I knew smoked weed and say
put your hand in and grab something and
they would all just pull out weed and
that was like my Christmas gift to
people so they knew I smoked weed so um
one of the events that I did being a
brand ambassador at the radio station I
started making my own events and I
started like you know doing my own
selling my own [__] products so
there was a headshot that I knew needed
advertising so I did a [__] sticker
stop event at a smoke shop I learned out
the owner of the smoke shop owned
dispensaries as well so when I left the
[__] radio he hired me to work at his
dispensary so 2009 I started Bud tending
right I became a patient like 2000 and
like six five four
thousand four I became a patient on
Sunset and then
uh I
started butts ending and I learned no
one knew what the [__] to look for they
came in and there's 30 jars and it's
like 40 different names and you know the
same weed is in each strain is it yeah
yeah you gotta try to hustle this [__]
and uh so I started podcasting and the
first things I started doing was just
letting people know
we know just we just basically like what
to look for like what PM looks like mold
but so when I started podcasting there
was no other marijuana type of show out
there everyone was scared there was one
show there was one show in Colorado
called marijuana radio but they were
more like political monotone kind of
like news worthy where I was trying to
bring in the culture and the lifestyle
and like the consumption aspect of it so
I started bringing in my customers from
the shop be it gross yeah on the show
because there wasn't a lot of people
that were open about it and I would meet
The Growers and want to talk about it
yeah were you filming it or is just on
on yeah stick them stick him do you
remember stick them no stick it was like
the first share screening Service uh
where you could 2009 you're doing this
yeah yeah so where you could like show
your screen and then you could have
other people's turn on their webcam and
they could join you live and [__] yeah
yeah it was like Zoom back then they
turned into JTV or Justin TV you heard
of that at the think JTV bought them out
and then that turned into like sounds
like some earlier
something and then twitch's [__]
Amazon now or so I mean it was like a
whole [__] but it was it was like super
before anyone and I was up there openly
smoking weed and it was just like so it
was so taboo back then you know no one
was Logan even made it on podcast and
smoking weed and all that [__] way way
before Joe Rogan yeah this is before Joe
Rogan's show well before him being even
yeah Joe Rogan was doing still Fear
Factor dude he was still the skinny guy
trying to have people eat whale penis
and [__] you know I had to explain my
new videographers from Russia East Far
East Russia and I had to explain to him
he said Joe Rogan my Fear Factor goes
what is Fear Factor oh my God I had to
explain to him yesterday like nah this
[__] make fools eat like bull
dicks people eat Bulldogs on TV and I
was like yeah I gotta get you on the
camera bro you don't know I gotta show
you all of your dude culture so yeah
speaking of Joker this is prior to him
smoking weed on like yeah him prior to
him being open yeah of weed smoking and
[__] for anyone like no one was really
open about smoking weed like I said I
just got a pizza job I mean yeah I don't
know call it like I don't know what it
was dude but I was like you know I'm a
[__] delicate dude from the valley of
[__] delicate dude
I was just open about my consumption I
knew there was nothing wrong with it I
would try to educate people I was
outcasting my family people were like oh
you smell like oh they didn't [__] with
you anymore but like what when I was
younger or not but I was like man y'all
are just uh [__] y'all the ones that
your mom and dad were okay with it well
they couldn't get mad at me but the
other people in your family were looking
like when I would go to like family like
I'm [__] 17 16. did you I'm smelling
like weed I look high and my family's
like what are you doing with your life
I'm living life bro like what do you
mean but like Fast Forward 10 15 years
later now they're hitting me up for
[__] weeks what are you supposed to
say to yourself it always [__] works
bro I had I had a family member who
owned warehouses and storefronts like he
had property and back in like
early 2000s I'm like yo can let me get
this Warehouse I will pay you I'm I'm
your family I want it to grow out a
little dude I wanted to like get the
[__] early but this is when the DEA was
sending letters to people like oh you
got weed or you got a weed store you got
to shut down and he was just not having
it and then a couple years later he's
like yo Adam I have 50 000 I want to do
something like go get a lawyer that's
what you're gonna do with your 50k and
then figure out what you want to do it's
too late now I appreciate you but we had
our opportunity 15 years ago
so I started butt attending dude and
that's where I started networking bro
like I met Growers I met hashmakers I
met people that were doing Publications
uh artists you know anyone would come in
to get it I had like fortune tellers
coming on my show I would have [__]
like random hats how long did you do
that show for so the podcast I had a
co-host it was a podcast with Adam ill
and Manny Bunce and we had that from
2009 till about like 13 14. oh we had
like we had like 500 shows dude [__]
yeah you guys are doing twice a week so
we were doing it it was once a week and
then we started doing Live Events I
started having actual like we would rent
out a [__] club and have like a
listener party because I came from Radio
you know what I'm saying so I learned
how like to organize all this [__] and
how to monetize and promote it and I
would get sponsors involved that wanted
to be a part of it because the way I
learned I could monetize off podcasting
is basically like I didn't know I didn't
know I just knew radio so I came into
podcasting and I would hit up a
dispensary and like yo listen let me get
an eighth of weed I'll talk about it on
my podcast I'll smoke it I'll give him a
code word if anyone comes in and says
like what or that mentions the show give
him a [__] free joint it's trim
anyway like you all already know this
shit's trapped back in the late [__]
like 15 years ago Dude give him a joint
give him 10 off whatever and then I
realized that
people were actually going to those
stores and using the codes and using the
code so I'm like yo I actually like my
Roi my return my return of investor like
you guys give me eighth I got you five
customers like you know what I got bills
I need to pay like [__] the eighth let
me catch the [__] cat and the eighth
or the ounce and I could smoke it and
and then that's how I started just
learning how to monetize and once
um me and my co-host just weren't on the
same page anymore he just did his [__]
and I was like all right and that's when
I changed the getting high with which
was like you know the first well I met
you 13 14. yeah and that's when I
started getting high with and what
happened was be real TV hit me up
because I was doing my show out of a
hash Lounge in the valley were you over
there Headroom Gallery well that's where
I met you that's the one with the secret
door that you go into the back this is
the [__] story you're talking about
that's where I met this guy first thing
I met you in 30 seconds and it went
oh my God you're just like my sister
my same person like the same my sister
is it good or bad look at my sister's a
dick everybody know for this I'm a dick
too no no no but the nice part of my
sister is super [__] cool and that's
the one I like like a very cool person
and then like oh you're mainly a
[__] though but those times when
you're cool as [__]
I was like as soon as you no not the
[__] part as soon as you start
talking like
goofy Falls just like my sister when
she's acting nice so the first thing I
thought was like I [__] with this guy I
met you through Tim yeah like 30 seconds
and it went oh yeah this guy's this
guy's cool well he was actually the
manager of that establishment and I was
badass I was doing my podcast out of
there I would set up my stage I remember
every week I would set it up I would
have a guest come in and I would have a
live studio audience it's like this room
but a little stage in the corner right
there everybody and I had a live studio
audience I would bring products and I
would bring people on we would do like
the hash competitions and I would have
the winner of the hash Club
I have me doing the hash competition
with Jerry K that long bong you press
the button and it clears okay remember
the long ass stick yeah yeah dude I will
send you the link after it's on my
channel yeah a long time ago well that's
the thing you've been consistent that's
why that's like I could I like I was
just filming stuff on my phone I don't
know bro but like the consistency you
have bro like you deserve everything
since the beginning but likewise bro
you're doing the same [__] like you were
at the same point yeah doing the same
stuff you've just been like doing it for
you and consistent with you my thing is
like I'm a people person I love helping
so like I'll go I'll stop what I'm doing
to come to you I'm like a universal
puzzle piece you know what I'm saying
like obviously those are like the host
of everything like we haven't got into
that yet I have it written as like the
Cannabis dude well so what happened is
so once I did solo Headroom Gallery I
was doing it there for a couple months
and I would have random people on it was
just creating a community a culture like
[__] nothing like this existed anywhere
dude like we were Pioneers in this [__]
and um once you know that [__] kind of
ran its course uh be real TV approached
me and they're like yo why don't you
just bring your show on our Network and
I was like you want me to be on be real
TV and back then you know b-roll TV was
just like it was like the cool thing
though it was like for me I'm like be
real legend I quote his songs daily like
it's it's a good platform I'm just a
regular dude in the valley who started
this podcast in a [__] studio
apartment in Valley Village at my
friend's house and having people come to
like yo where's your show oh it's in the
studio apartment like my guests weren't
as I mean I've had great guests
throughout the years I've had amazing
guests but then once you know I had that
be real TV platform and this type of
approval so people also wanted to come
because they're like yo is be real gonna
be there that's why he does a Smoke Box
a Cadillac so it's like a better venue
for me to book yes and and I and shout
out to be for giving me the opportunity
I appreciate that but um so I was there
and I brought I feel like I brought the
culture to be real TV because it was
mostly it was mostly hip hop it was
Cypress Hill he smoked weed like Soul
Assassins but it wasn't like the culture
of cannabis online of cat because I get
it when I first started smoking weed I
didn't know about like a weed Community
I always thought it was like taboo there
was random Growers if you knew someone
you got it but like the more I got
involved the more I networked the more I
realized that you know there's activists
there's Growers there's uh you know
drivers there's trimmers like there's a
community and you start and then when I
started interviewing them all and giving
them their the the flowers that they
deserve because a lot of people don't
get the flowers immediately and um I was
just getting them on praising them I
would have uh genetic Award winners
anytime I hosted a High Times Cannabis
Cup well before we get into that high
times because that's a big part of your
[__] life it's what I wanted to get
into let's stay on the b-roll because I
don't want to go
I got you so yeah not be real TV and
then like my caliber of guests started
just getting amazing like David Arquette
I had David Arquette I would have had
like Rue Jude I'd have Daz and corrupt I
would have like just it's just a
different platform of like okay not just
weed people I would I brought in my yes
well I've always tried to like snow I'm
saying like the weeds there but you were
starting to get like bigger people who
smoked weed because they never saw
Trinidad James on your show yes when he
was just starting to get the gold just
came out yeah when he just dropped you
were a [__] [__] shirt I remember
hell yeah I mean I wore him you know I
support my homies if I have a platform
and the least I could do is wear your
hat or a shirt or have your bag on my
[__] table like I'll I will do that
for you because what what is it it's
just [__] I appreciate your support
your hustle and I would love I love
everyone to succeed there's enough room
for everybody and I think that's what
got [__] up in the spaces too many
egos started coming out and I mean we
could get into that once it became a
legal uh in the states it started
getting really weird but I was on be
real TV dude it was a good run uh I did
a lot I feel like you know I brought a
lot of people there that were in the
space
um you know from award-winning extract
artists to content creators and just
help them Network and then uh you know
that was a question why did you guys
leave I for me to you we're on the show
here we go so I was there I did like
three years with be real TV I remember I
like you know did a bunch of [__] I was
getting a lot of more people involved
with that Network
um what happened is
basically I I didn't know I don't know
the politics I don't know everything I
don't know what relationships people
have with everyone I don't know who you
like and who you don't like and who you
don't [__] with you know what I'm saying
but I thought everyone that I met
through b was cool would be so I got
invited to some event and when I came
back he's like yo like what are you
doing going to this dude's event and I'm
like like what
he's like yeah it's either like you know
like I thought you like I thought
everything was cool and he's like no
like if you're gonna [__] with him you
can't be here anymore
I was like you know what dude I
appreciate everything but like I think
like look I respect B for giving me the
opportunity but like you know I wasn't
getting paid by be real TV I was just
doing my [__] and I was able to monetize
it on my own
um and I would you know compensate them
for you know helping me out and giving
me the platform every once in a while
but you know once he told me that I was
just like you know what dog like I
appreciate it you know I wish it didn't
end like this and I was like and I just
moved on bro yeah
I don't really I I respect everyone I
don't realize it's not like going around
talking [__] I know you well yeah I
don't never asked like my Instagram got
deleted right after I wasn't [__]
with them anymore which was weird which
was like the first kind of like moment I
was like man what the [__] is this
Instagram [__] because it was still new
you know what I'm saying they could do
that because I mean him and I and you
still get deleted I mean we I get
deleted all the time I haven't even
posted on my Instagram in a [__] week
now dude because every time I I could
post my [__] dog and I'll get it
taken down for nudity and nudity for the
dog yeah dude he puts his dog got nude
do I need to put a shirt on my dog now
when I post soon what is this a boxing
what is this dude but um so yeah it's
not like a [__] talking thing at all
like I've known this happened years ago
and I never even asked yeah yeah yeah
personally we've been buyers and I never
even asked yeah and you know I was
bringing in like I always wondered I was
bringing in sponsors to there and like
yeah I get it but you guys this didn't
work out anymore that's all it's it's
kind of like an ultimatum and I was and
I wasn't I'm not a yes man you know what
I'm saying oh that's kind of [__] up
yeah it kind of left a sour tasting like
I get it but then again it's a great run
yeah but then it's like but I'm very
cordial I respect them but you know
there were some other people on the crew
that were just kind of disrespectful and
and talking weird afterwards and I was
like you know what bro I thought we were
homies when I was there you guys acted
like my homies and now like that I'm
gone y'all are doing this like it's cool
that's a bummer man yeah that's that's
all right I mean the [__] we learned you
know what I'm saying I had a great time
he gave me a lot of opportunities I met
a lot of people I had some great shows
on there yeah
um you broke your [__] sad what yo
all I remember is the look on his face
got so serious then went oh that was a
real moment one of your bomb ass
on his show one of the guests just kind
of knocked it over and it's got to
happen a lot I would think right no that
was all the only time
I mean the value is in the with glass
you know it's like all right I mean at
the time it was valued at like 15K it
was like a collab but the thing that
upset me is like I wouldn't even get an
apology for it it was more like I'm
sorry that happened while I was on your
show not like yo that's [__] up I
knocked it over what can I do let me
help you out and I know this fool gets
booked and I know this [__] and then he
started talking [__] about glass blowers
and the Art of glasses they broke your
rig it's saying Glass isn't really that
hard to do wrapping is a lot harder I
was like [__] I can rap right
now but put me behind the torch I won't
be able to make a [__] marble like
lick a dick uh this guy named Emrick
wait it was Denmark that broke yeah oh
that's it and then started talking [__]
about glasses yeah I know that's why I
was like yo I didn't know that I know
him very well I know I know him very
well too I know I know
I just remember the piece breaking and I
saw your face go
like like when you almost get hit by a
car like I saw it in your face like the
terror goes through it it was a collab
it was like it's never gonna be made
again never be made one of the artists
doesn't even make glass anymore now he
moved on to like creating uh like he
designs bars and houses he takes like
wine barrels and wine glass bottles and
makes like chandeliers and like desks he
just deconstructs him he pulls the wine
bottles it's very cool he's that art
basil he's like he's like why am I gonna
make a [__] 100 pipe when I could
make a [__] hundred and fifty
thousand dollar installment and I'm like
bro like [__] congrats I just remember
the rib snap smashing the pieces because
there was an email I think attached to
it and I just remember oh there's in on
the table and I just want to see your
face
from that day I that becoming a heady
boy and only smoke blunts
[Laughter]
the bong's at my crib if you watch my
stream I still [__] with glass I
appreciate it but because of that and
like the value and like the like I was
like yeah you know what I'm not even
gonna like why why spend so much I
wasn't half your baseball card
collection going should I start over
yeah like what am I gonna do this again
like all that money and it was it was
like I didn't get it for what it was you
know I got it for a good price and I
just know yeah it's like it's not even
the money it's like yo this will never
be me never it just took my whole like
just every like oh you just burned my
script that's what you saw in my face
it's just like I saw your face I saw it
it was your love for glasses
I still appreciate all glass blowers
thank you for your Innovation making
dabs a lot easier and flower with your
little arts and the cards and the
[__] pearls and everything thank you
guys but it's just my passion for it is
just not what it was that was it that
was at least it was PTSD though it's
different it was bad it was bad like my
Bongos bought was expensive yeah his
bong is seven
and I would [__] be so hurt not in
the money just like and I've broken many
rings like glasses glass like certain
glass you're like I don't give a [__] if
it breaks this is like I'll flip Rigs
and catch them remember the flipping
yeah yeah I remember flipping great days
this [__] used to heat up you
guys remember I don't know if you
remember red flips
fifteen thousand ten thousand dollar
pieces Jesus Christ every time heat it
up not everything grab it by the neck
and flip it and catch it and take a dab
they were flipping their [__] rings
in the sky
but we didn't have to do the bottle flip
yeah
I mean I've done the bottle flips with
the rigs that are like quality made yeah
but do you remember this I made a skit
one time when I used to make only skits
on Instagram yeah I was like I wanted to
be a part of that one I just made it in
my house and I'm like all these
[__] rig flipping I was talking
[__] about everybody like in a funny way
and I just walked up my rig I flipped it
and the [__] never [__] came down
and I just stood there for a while the
clip just kind of ended and what five
years later you're like yo we should
just have your rig finally
yo let me catch your ring five years
five years the account got deleted I
don't have the [__] clip anymore
that's all that happened that's what I
hate about Instagram too dude like some
of the content I saved but then like
other [__] I don't know it's like sent
to me or is it DM that someone gave me
and it's gone bro forever and I'm just
not organized like that to save my
content I have too many pictures I have
to get a new phone and do this do that
and it's just too much and I lose a lot
it's like that bro
um damn but yeah be real TV
thank you three years professional I was
there uh so I had a great moments dude
and I feel like that also elevated me
and my brand my name uh within the space
like I kind of got more it was a stamp
of approval yeah it was like be real
[__] with you you're on the [__] and
then like is one of the but when it
comes to weed but before I get to be
real like let me shout out Cali
Connection real quick and my boy swerve
who kind of got me the first real gig
like after Bud tending he was a an
award-winning geneticist he's created a
bunch of strains he's chill I worked
with him for many many years
um in his garden that's how I learned I
was there separating seeds I was hooking
people up with seeds before anyone
really cared about seeds and uh you know
from there uh I got to you know because
I had a platform to do my show at Cali
Connection where I got a lot more of the
like weed people involved because they
respected that brand and I would get
like you know at that time they started
testing in weed so I'd get like
scientists and and more Growers and [__]
so it was it was shout out to kind of
connection and then be real TV and then
after that uh well during that well
during b-roll TV I started it's you all
right I had secret sauce I had all the
events I had to get into that I'm
talking about High Times cannabis cups
yeah when it comes if you've ever been
to the High Times Cannabis Cup you have
to have seen Adam's face
no matter what you're on every you are
the like doing this stuff right there
doing [__] like that yeah so you were
the host of all the High Times cannabis
cups even introduced ever all these
[__] every artist that's ever
been there this Fool's like the one that
all right coming up next yeah I was very
fortunate about so what happened with
that is back to Cali Connection is
um the first ever High Times Cannabis
Cup in La was like 2012 or 13. I went to
the 13th 14th yeah it was the one in La
though the center studios not in River
it wasn't in uh San Bernardino it was
actually downtown L.A with like the LA
then I went to the next one okay so this
was like 12 or 13. it was a high time I
actually bought a ticket actually waited
in line to get in oh [__] that was a
regular ass [__] civilian go into
this event I'm like let me see what this
[__] is dude like it's High Times all
the high time events were in Amsterdam
like this is the first La High time just
legal issue with 215. so they're here so
I went and I was [__] bored it was a
swap meet there was just a bunch of
boots selling [__] there was no one
engaging with the people everyone was
just trying to sell you their [__]
pipe or their weed or their bong or
their it was great but it was it was I
was bored as [__] so the next day I told
Cali Connection I was working with him
I'm like get a [__] Booth get a one
day Booth I'm gonna bring my podcast
equipment and I want to [__] wait the
Cali Connection where you did the booth
was the first time you ever did this the
next one the first so the next High
Times were you was at San Francisco so
that was that was when we actually
planned it and I had a little like
soapbox it was this is what I'm talking
about yeah I have this on film yeah that
was that was like the second High Times
I did yeah I have this one I started at
a booth I didn't start on the main stage
I know what you're talking about it was
a booth and you stood up on this little
thing and I and you were talking in the
crowd throwing [__] out to freaking [__]
out getting people high it celebrating
one of the most things I've ever filmed
what you have that I have you on tape
and some guy was being a [__] dick to
you one dude I know who yeah okay yeah
what about I don't remember some guy was
yelling you were yelling back and I was
like I wasn't yelling back I was
questioning it no that so that was the
whole pie guy cookies controversy oh
Kenny Powers because we had wait that
was nice that wasn't yes dude that's how
long ago I know
yeah dude this is like almost a decade
ago now
that's the first [__] one of the
first things I ever filmed when it comes
to weed events ever because I remember
Cali Connection was black and white yeah
a black white fox
silhouette it was I thought it was like
more like Godfather looking Godfather
exactly yeah okay yeah it was The
Godfather Cali Connection
you know what's crazy is you were right
next to the fence yes yeah because I
remember everything from what I was
looking at yeah yeah
wow
a long time ago yeah I do you say you
don't have a good memory get the [__]
out of here I mean a lot of these people
just remember where it was I can
remember looking at you just because
I've seen the video so many times I
remember it like oh there's moments I
don't remember because there's no
content but people don't remember that
[__] in their head forever dude I was
filming I was like whoa so that was the
second one so the first one was just
kind of a pop-up I had a speaker and a
microphone and our sound board and I was
just talking [__] to the crowd hyping up
Cali Connection because I was bored on
Saturday so I remember this so Sunday
I'm like yo let me bring some
[__] energy here let me talk to
people let me make this a factual
[__] event because I came from Radio
dude so like being in radio I knew how
to [__] turn a parking lot into a
party a host I was like I'm the MC I
emceed the Raider games I was at went to
local bars that's the Raider MC you know
when you go to a bar and on a football
game and they'll have like a beer
sponsor it's like so I'm with that guy I
was with that was a radio station with
the beer so I was working with all these
models dude all these beer I was 18
working with all these [__] promo
models inside a bar hyping up the
Raiders like I'm like wait what am I
doing oh this is this is the weed and
I'll be posting it on MySpace dude and
then Facebook came out and it started
being a Facebook thing and then I
started getting all these like weed
groups on Facebook and being a part of
this bigger culture because that was
more National on with cannabis it wasn't
just localized so now I started getting
cannabis on the national so and Cali
connections worldwide so I started the
first Cannabis Cup La hosting Cali
connects I had like Rob Van Dam pop on
my show dude and for me that was a
stoner boner moment you know what I'm
saying because I Stoner boner moments
for me are like those moments when
you're a teenager smoking weed and like
you're like yo smoking with Snoop Dogg
being in High Times [__] having a
weed stray name after me you know like
bucket list [__] but for weeds I call
them Stoner boner moments so like so
like smoking with rap RVD
Monday night you know rbd420 I was like
yo what let's [__] go and
so bringing this energy to the booth and
like actually having fun there he
brought me he actually set up a booth
next time and then every time we set up
it got bigger and then we went to
Amsterdam for the high time that was my
first time and we had a whole setup and
then Vader Village became a part of it I
remember that Vader Vader extracts
became a thing and then we turned it
into a [__] concert we brought an
actual legit stage we had our own
[__] stage look like an actual oh
[__] High Times had their stage but
all their entertainment was at night and
at night time you're already burnt out
tired you were in the cup you were
walking around a parking lot for eight
hours smoking weed like I don't want to
wait till 10 o'clock to see a [__]
rapper like yeah so we brought the party
throughout the day giving out weed I was
on that bike you got to explain the
stage though it was like
uh Madonna concert style stage it was an
actual production [__] stage with
white stage manager and all that crazy
[__] audio it was like a legitimate
brand did this but we we included like
we called it Vader Villas because what
we ended up doing was bringing our
family involved so a bunch of like La
SoCal brands that were involved were in
this you know Cali Connection Invader we
had green wolf was a part of it there
was um you know that we had a whole
bunch I remember there was a moment
where he wasn't in it but he was near it
and we had a little incident I had to
apologize for Thomas yes yes so that was
so so what happened so basically you say
that so good I'll tell you what happened
to that right now so basically what
ended up happening is me hosting
Cali Connection Booth from a little
microphone and a speaker and growing
every year bringing it in a DJ starting
production getting a bigger stage High
Times finally reached out to me because
I every time I was there I was like yo
if you need anyone to announce an award
or if you need anyone to be a part of it
like I'm here that first stage where you
guys brought all those artists was just
Vader to pay for that yeah we that was
elevator Village yeah like two chains
you guys brought out a bunch of art we
brought an artist we wanted to see D12
let's go what the [__] I didn't realize
you guys had well you know we brought
out Rae Sremmurd I remember when all
these fools were just starting yeah they
were just getting into it and we're like
yo what's up like the first year we got
it was like
the first year we got Rae Sremmurd it
was cool the next time we try to book
them they charged us double of what they
originally booked because they because
the Denver crowd was the biggest crowd
ever that was the biggest crazy that was
my favorite High Times event ever that
was insane how about the crowds yeah it
was like 40 000 people like a [__]
Festival Vibe it was insane it was a
festival but so doing all these small
events and just being you know ambitious
and knowing what I want and talking the
high times and building a relationship
with them and like yo if you need me on
stage let me know blah blah blah and
then as their people started getting
older they wanted like that new young
fresh so they're like yo
announced an award and then the
announcing award turned into hosting the
award show and then hosting the award
show it turned into doing the whole [__]
by myself because I was hosting it I was
announcing the winners and I was [__]
interviewing everyone really think about
it because the High Times theme like
that will never come back it'll never be
as dope it'll never be as cool it
doesn't it don't matter and I was
traveling and you hosted all of it I was
getting I mean I had a booth at every
one yeah Stoner boner moment like I was
getting paid and getting flown out to
like all across the country it was very
cool man all across the country hosting
dude and I got to meet the communities
within every state I got to go to
Michigan because of weed I got to go to
Colorado because we Seattle or Seattle
remember that one time I said one time I
saw this guy and he was just like [__]
up just rapping freestyle and it was
terrible and at the end I realized I
wasn't recording and I'm like it was
David Arquette yeah on my stage
recording it's like five minutes my yo
this was [__] ah I just have the last
three seconds of that I have
but yeah so that was like the [__] we
were doing I was I was actually getting
high with like it was cool yeah it was
it was because because my perspective is
oh I can hear Adam wow
still because I was I run a booth at
every event you already know we have
hella fools come through yeah it was
dope every time but like my thing was
like oh there's that I'm going by the
camera on this [__] microphone talk
all right yeah later man because my
perspective is this side I hate that's
before I I would be so scared to be on
stage ever in life well I remember you
were the first time I had you I had you
on my b-real TV episode like the first
time on getting high whistle and you're
like yo I've never done anything like
this and I'm like bro don't trip we're
just hanging out smoking weed and like
when I did my set it was two recliner
chairs that Lazy Boy recliners so y'all
felt comfortable and at a table full of
product weed dabs Edibles Vape carts
whatever you wanted because I'm not
forcing you to smoke but if you want to
yeah it's there and that's how I learned
how to monetize this that's product
placement yeah so yo yeah you want you
want this my guest to smoke your [__]
then this is how much it costs this is
what you need to [__] give me and
I'll put it right there and it's not
going to be forced and if they do it
shout out if not you got your placement
yep
no for real but yeah I had you on you
know I would I gave a lot of people I
feel like I've given a lot of people
their first like podcast interviews
there's not doing anything there was
nobody doing anything when it comes to
speaking involving weed yeah I was never
ashamed of my consumption there was
never anybody on any platform I could
think of not even ggn yet no no there
was nothing yeah it was me
uh that marijuana radio out of Colorado
which was very like political based and
then late like I think bong grip had
like a little live stream but it was
like a little weird but there wasn't
like content of I was doing lifestyle
[__] because I started you know doing
weekly events so like we would be
smoking pound Blunts and taking Graham
Globs and covering blunts with 10 gram
slabs this is all on this is all
recorded yeah there's video of this [__]
around and like this is before anyone
was even doing this before like you
would get reported on Instagram for [__]
like this and when I first started doing
Instagram yeah this is when people would
share your [__] happily because they've
never seen [__] and it was cool
they actually tagged you and didn't just
steal it and say it was theirs and take
all credit when you started getting all
these [__] fake accounts who follow
each other and buy each other followers
and just shout each other out and try to
sell you each other DMS just try to
circle jerk each other then come to you
and be like hey we got this network and
like yeah your network is fake yeah it's
only one guy one guy one guy with a
bunch of butts yeah that's a whole other
[__] story yeah I don't know if we're
talking about that but no I'm saying but
before that you I'm saying but what we
get into see eyes Circle back oh we get
back into it it'll never be another time
like that it's it will never come back
as strong I will never work another
[__] booth in my life I am done I did
a [__] 500 in the past eight years
I'm good yeah I've stood for too long in
Vans yeah I'm over it well they're not
the same they're not what they they're
not gonna be fun they're not gonna be
fun I mean it's a whole different it's
not a it's not a community anymore it's
not even like an industry now it's like
a [__] circus because there's so many
clowns involved and it's just never
gonna be the same it used to be like we
all used to be here for each other help
each other out as Community we all were
like yeah make it legal let's [__]
we're all on the same page 215. and then
once it became legal and you had like
people that were still in trap and then
people that were like transitioning to
compliance and then they were hating on
each other and would start snitching
each other out and it wasn't like a team
anymore and people had Egos and like I'm
first this is my [__] I'm not into that
because I never [__] with Brands I
know so I don't know what the [__]
you're talking about I didn't know that
was going on oh this is I mean now it's
just like what do you mean who what was
going on well just like people were just
like mad at other people
or like like that kind of [__] like that
like oh their store is open they're not
even legal and then [__] like yo he
doesn't even have the real strains he
can't even call him that like he's lying
those are my genetics I started that
[__] it's like why are you so just like
I get it do what you do straight
business yeah people just started hating
on each other it was just like egos
they're like that's mine not his and
businesses started splitting and then
you started getting the same
same product to label two different ways
and then they would talk [__] about each
other but it's the same [__] [__] I
do remember as a consumer you're like yo
what the [__] bro like I thought we're
all on the same team and it just became
gross dude and then like people want you
to pick sides and you're just like bruh
like smoking weed I'm just trying to get
high enough thank you but I've never got
involved with the legal aspect like this
well I'm like you were doing so much
events so many events product plays with
this you have to talk to these people
I'm like a personality I'm more like a
host so like I'm yeah it's different for
you and like you do content yeah working
like all want you to be like no you're
you know you're [__] you you agree with
me right yeah [__] that guy agree with
me like yeah it's our platform and
people want to use our platform to
promote their products like there was
never when I was growing up dude there
was nothing as like I want to be an
influencer I want to be a YouTube Star I
want to be a tick tock like I was just
posting [__] that I was passionate about
which is weed and food my girl and my
dog like that's what it was but I had
access to Crazy amounts of weed and I
was documenting it because I didn't give
a [__] I wasn't hiding I wasn't in the
closet smoker I was out there I was open
and that [__] you know how it is that
[__] goes once you do something crazy I
remember the first I think my first
viral video was me smoking a bong blunt
it was a blunt the picture of this yeah
you have a straight half your glasses
and the Flames that's what I was at work
yeah it was like it was it was like
that was a blunt but I took a dab out of
it yeah I remember it it was like a
built-in and it put a big blunt put a
hole in it put a dab nail in it made it
tight enough heated the nail took a dab
while the blow is lit while hitting the
blood and the cherries like bigger
the Cherry was about like that big and
it combed out to a beaker bomb so you
smoke the dab while it blunt yeah it was
stupid it was ridiculous this is like
almost 10 years ago now you know what
I'm saying
world star of this [__] hitting
backwards and throwing knives
you probably seen I call them 11 30s yes
so basically he had this fat ass back
when he was dropping big hash clubs and
[Music]
that was on me yeah I have some dabs oh
man first first concentrates on the show
oh really we don't ever [__] because
YouTube's such a jerk with it they're
like no go for it I want you to do I
just don't have a dab tool right now so
I'm gonna need to find something that's
I can't actually
pull off
but yeah so I do 11 30 so basically for
me
um I'm into all consumption I love it I
don't give I don't I don't uh
consumption shame if you love carts and
distillate that's all you or you should
sometimes consumption shame you know
what this guy does the other we wonder
what this guy does you guys know what
rosin is
you squish weed right and it comes out
the oil and you can dab it this
[__] rolls back woods
listen he would roll blunts thank you
Marty thank you
and then put it in a rosin press and
squeeze it so you would rosin the
[__] tobacco with the weed and it
would dab like the blunt yeah it was
disgusting delicious
yeah and the thing is we were trying to
convince two-tone like yo how much would
it cost yeah I mean for you to eat this
rosin backwood he's like two thousand
dollars twenty five hundred I was like
what about a little lower and then Omar
ratchet man unprovoked walks in we
didn't ask him to do this he just grabs
it back when it goes
[Laughter]
I have the video bro it was ridiculous
it was posted I haven't I think it's
posted on my YouTube that isn't really
active but yeah
um
but yeah so I love squishing uh blunt
rosin Blossom is my thing dude gross
it's like an amazing terpene that you
will never experience I bet you love it
but so listen so listen this is my thing
dude it's like this nation our country
United States of America started off
with that listen listen
this nation loves to do things different
right like
the way we measure things is way
different we don't use the metric system
like the rest of the world we use like I
just found that out we use like feet and
yards and like kilos everyone else
doesn't use ourselves no we're the only
ones and we're the only nation that
like hates weed and tobacco like oh that
shit's disgusting it's gross everyone I
know smokes blunts I'm the only one that
smokes joints no everyone in them
everyone out here what did you just say
no I know people that like oh you mix
your weed and tobacco you're gross
there's a lot of there's a lot of peers
out there that are oh they're shame my
homie smoked uh were they called uh
bowls with tobacco in it what is it
called cookies or uh not pookies no no I
mean mookies or Moki mokes smokes
Smokies
I was like what is he doing bro
yeah most yeah but like that's the I
mean if you look at anywhere in the
world like Europe Middle East
Asia it's tobacco makes a weed because
cannabis is an amazing feminine plant
and it gives us a lot of amazing things
and then tobacco is an amazing masculine
plant and wheat gets a lot of it's got a
lot of hate in the States but tobacco
you know it's it's natural it's a good
natural pesticide for your garden
it what your shock tobacco is a good
natural person yeah if you grow tobacco
no if you grow tobacco next to like your
garden like it won't get infested with
like because even though they know
they're like no it's natural but
tobacco's sweet dude it has an amazing
flavor Associated tobacco with bats yeah
and backwards it's like saying like
people that only smoke think of blunt
says backwards is like thinking
McDonald's has the best hamburgers like
just because they're the most popular
doesn't mean they're the best you know
what I'm saying like there's so many you
just smoked what the Grabber I smoke
Brothers I smoke Brothers broad Leafs
dude yo those are so [__] hard to get
uh you you I know you know these I know
you got that these are like the the good
backwood so you just put everybody on
right now that watches our Channel if
you smoke backwards stop yeah so
backwards just aren't quality leaves
they're just like mass produced and
they're not consistent you buy a five
pack I know a lot of people complain
about this you use two or three of them
you open them up there's holes there's
stems there's weird colors and you're
like what the [__] is this mold you call
backwards and you're like hey what's up
[__] you well like on the back so on the
back of a pack it has a questions or
comments please call us so you could
call them and we've called my boy Bert
called also and when you tell them like
hey I opened the Backwoods and there was
nothing they go our cigars aren't made
to be unrolled
for a court yeah great answer dude I
appreciate that but you know what [__]
you because because your main clients
are cannabis consumers I know two people
that smoke backwards as regular cigars
and they're over 60 years old yeah and
they smoke them like this they
whatever it is dude but there's two I
know two people that spoke backwards
like that and they're over 60. everyone
else I know
unrolls them and my boys over here
Paxton and Dawson they [__] care
about their customers their brothers the
Brand's called Brothers broadleafs yeah
Brothers broadly yeah Brothers Bradley
it's like Supreme drops yeah they're
they have certain drops I mean it
depends what pack you're trying to get
they have different like they have their
trap homies or like you can get though
they saw me post with you one time like
who's your homie with like [__] five
boxes of these yeah I got them saying
look these are the havanas these are the
Cuban those are the Cubans this is not
an ad and I don't smoke backwards or
[__] any type of time I'm a real
smoker so I know he smokes this [__]
yeah for everyone out there that needs
something to smoke so I suggest that I
love cigars and they actually care about
their clients you saw like here I'm
Gonna Roll oh I already rolled it but
you see the inside is like wrapped in
another Leaf because there's no mess
like yeah that way there's no mess with
Backwoods there's like tobacco that goes
everywhere and they bind it and they're
all consistent there's no stems that
interrupt no holes they have the Duds
these are their these are they're almost
perfect these are their imperfect ones
these are still
but these might have a little
imperfections and Liz says a little
thing almost perfect yeah and then they
have Canadians and then they have these
are the real ones like the broad leaves
I love that I mean I'm a real smoker I
[__] like quality leaves I tired of
spending
eight ten dollars on a break to only
smoke like two or three of them yo it's
the worst pissed off so Philly Blunts
and Dutch Masters just that's all right
East Coast that's East Coast [__] okay
Phillies Dutch Masters white I was
Garcia Vegas sweaters every [__] day
anymore though right yeah yeah no every
day there's new smokers and uneducated
people out there until you like learn
something and you're really passionate
then you start learning the levels to it
with anything in life be it Sports be it
food be it fashion whatever you have the
basic and then if you really are
passionate you start getting really
involved and that's just how it is with
tobacco I've tried tobacco from all over
the country I've had Mexican land races
uh Argentinian Brazilian uh these are
from Nicaragua I've had uh so like I
like trying different tobacco and this
[__] culture being in the gang
effect between the masculine energy of
the tobacco plant and The Feminine
energy just gives me a a better feeling
than I was doing tobacco that's the only
reason I'm not I'm not mad yeah that's
all I used to smoke blunts all [__]
day too but when I bought that box of
swishers that has all the packs oh I
felt like a [__] baller but like I
was I didn't smoke flour at all between
2000 and like 13 to 15. I was like
yeah and now you don't dab at all
right Dad what do you mean I got [__]
I still die oh you see you don't take
dabs no more no I doubt I'm just a 95
flower consumer and then like five
percent dabbing I don't dab it was I'm
like 90 10. but when I dab me and you
know super J yeah we could [__] help
yeah but I still like I like rosin I got
BHO like I still dab but it's not my
preferred way of consuming and that's
why I say I'm not I do not smoke
distillate I am anti-distolid but if you
smoke it good for you but to me
distillate started as trash
like no one ever to hide it no one ever
makes has good weed and go we're turning
this into distillate that's true as in
Vape carts as in car yeah that's true
like no one ever has like a good [__]
grow and like oh this is gonna make fire
distillate no they wash it or the
scientists are gonna go but you the pro
you know the process it's actually good
now but yeah we get it yeah but it's
like you've tricked me
just strip everything off of the plant
so if it's trash if it's trim if it's
like bottom of the barrel you could
still get some essential ingredients to
creation and it's crude it turns out
like black it's like the gross it's like
crota oil and then what they do it's
like it's like drinking purified water
like purified water used to be sewage
water until they process it and make it
drinkable yeah I didn't know that you're
running through filters you run it
through filters you clean it you
separate all the trash all that bad [__]
is out you get the main ingredient then
you
CRC it color even with water you do the
CRC you you change the color you add
some [__] so it looks clean you run it
you clean it you test it until there's
no
foreign objects in it and then you have
your product that's clean but it was
trash to begin with and I'm not hating
on distillate
it's great for people that want sneak
hits or you know wines are great but I
am a I love flower I love the process I
love smelling the nugs I love looking at
the nugs I love feeling connected
rolling it up it's like a whole process
for me so there's no company out there
doing distance let's right look there's
like rock like carts now it's like
pre-rolls like when pre-rolls first came
out they were all garbage they were left
in here when you dump Ebola yeah or they
were like processed it was like already
blasted weed that they would wrap I
remember that I won't say what cone or
it was like certain company horrible
weed that was dipped in crude distillate
like oil before they cleaned it he
dipped in horrible Kief and you're like
oh this is gonna [__] you up and it left
a bad name for pre-rolls for everybody
but these days you could find decent
pre-rolls people put quality weed in
their pre-rolls just like carts there
are decent carts out there there are uh
live resin carts there are rosin carts
there's there's good clean distillate
but you just got to remember just so it
started as trash
most 99.9 of the time this lit was
started as like no hey just saw that
just like McDonald's chicken it's
[__] what is it pink slime it's like
it starts as garbage and then they
process it and make it look like it's
white meat
yeah pretty crazy yeah it's pretty
[__] crazy to compare it but that's
exactly what it is but I'm just trying
to like put it like that all right so
this is an 11 30 dude going back to it
so this is what you saw in world star
but I do it a little different now is 11
30 for me because this is 420 which is
the world what we know as weed and 710
is what we know as oil me being Jewish I
put the numbers together and I got 11
30. and 11 30 to me is a lot more
convenient time to smoke am or p.m it's
uh both I don't discriminate on either
one and I just put my dab and I put it
on top of the Cherry like that and then
I just [__] inhale it
you can take a dab and then I get it
stuck on there then I hit it super smart
it's honestly very smart
I used to do this on cigarettes when I
used to go to theme parks yeah because
you can't do anything else I know how
helpful to throw hash in their
cigarettes yeah they coat the whole end
in cash you just smoke yeah I do that
you can't dab I would put the top I
would cover the top with that the whole
thing I would do a little round around
the outside the whole thing melt
remember those
remember that guy it's such a waste it's
such a waste but if you're in a [__]
because if you're into it that's like
that a lot 11 30s try it at home dude
it's fun it's cool
I actually did an 11 30 holiday dude I
actually did I was there fool I know I
win it was a good time
um
so real quick real quick let me change
it up uh-oh so one time I was uh I was
Man on the street one time I did the man
on the tree thing but at the Weedmaps
party remember okay Weedmaps Coachella
party oh yeah yeah we had the house yes
so there was this big ass mansion with
this little piece of [__] I used to film
with it was with for one of his things
anyway I was back there and they were
doing like the Hannibal Buress and the
ray schrammer pools and they were doing
that I might go home first we'll hit
this joint had a joint this [__]
the YouTube thumbnail
remember the YouTube down there that big
eyes joint uh-huh it's that one that's
the day that's the day I'm talking about
so I get there I'm doing my hosting
thing just you know doing [__] see all
these rappers I know I'm like okay
interviewing whatever cool cool Adam's
there
so I'm leading this into a question all
right stick around
I love it
so I'm there you know I'm doing my [__]
and I love art music so I see certain
Rams I'm like oh hell yeah cool
so I see a certain rapper he's shooting
a basketball oh he's shooting a
basketball I have this on tape it's on
my YouTube uh and I'm like
sick I just bought this Fool's album
tight and I shoot the basketball and I
miss anyway I'm with the microphone and
then he shoots the basketball gets the
ball back and then you're there with the
microphone too
and he's recording something
and then this certain artist gets the
basketball and chest throws it hard as
[__] rappers don't like me dude toward
Adam and I was like oh do they know each
other
why does Action Bronson not like you
damn dude what a [__] intro thank you
I had to intro I'm a Storyteller
so my question is why did it actually
yeah like so violent I forgot about that
dude I didn't I remember no now that you
brought up that story and that house and
I remember the whole thing and who I was
there with and what I was doing which
was a whole other chapter in my life uh
he did single me out there huh I just
went
do they know because I don't know
actually give him a lot of rap beef he's
like I [__] forgot about this one
dude like you know when you throw the
ball like you take it out [__] yeah he
did that to Adam he had a microphone and
I was like oh that was a traditional
ketchup
when the ball makes that noise it did
that when he caught it like oh yeah
there was power behind that and I just
kept doing my thing and I went huh so
I'll ask about that later so that
particular artist we didn't say there
are the names
it's okay it's it's hey thing I just
wanted to know yeah I don't know if he
doesn't like me but I know it definitely
doesn't like what his boys has a problem
with me and uh
I called one of his boys out for an
incident he did on my podcast oh that's
what the [__] happened yeah so you know
I was doing my podcast so what happened
is you remember we used to do the big
blunts remember that we I had all the
[__] big blunts stuff
in rocket launchers or [__]
saxophones or my face or whatever the
[__] crazy [__] just just designed
however it is so um there was a blunt
that was a guitar a full guitar wasn't
that at the cup though it was that
chalice chalice it was that challenge
you were on stage with the I wasn't on
stage with it I could talk it was a full
guitar I know the roller he spent hours
like days rolling this smokable blunts
smokable art so
I wasn't the host at this particular
event they didn't have me hosted they
wanted to go with someone else at this
event chalice so yes uh so this
particular event
um the host at that time was very like
timid
like eager and
[__] wanted to get [__] done so he
not realized it's a guitar but it's a
blunt so he grabs the blunt out of the
dude's hand and it's a [__] blunt and
it cracks a little bit and it breaks a
little bit in certain spots right so
then when the blunts presented
to the rapper and they go to smoke it
it doesn't light because there's like
holes in it now from the aggression that
of grabbing the blunt right
so when they try lighting it they like
flaming it right so it's like all
cherried up but the air is not coming
through it's got a crack but but they're
like torching it and you know these
blunts the cherries get like bigger than
heads and once the blunt wasn't lighting
but it's still like the Cherry it's like
the front is lit this dude throws it
into the crowd while the blunt is lit
his boy
a lot of weed and a lot of time that the
artist put into it right big ass blunt
throws it into the crowd
they hit someone in the face the Cherry
Falls you know there's weed have you
ever hit someone yeah like some girl
complained about it it was like [__] it
that's a dangerous thing to do bro so I
to log you through a flaming log he just
threw a big ass blunt into the crowd
that was lit fire right instead of like
passing it or whatever dude because
we've done this imagine that party Foul
that cherry dropped
I mean it's happened a lot but I just
said something on my show about it
oh wait so this happens you're not even
there no I was at the event I was in the
crazy one I saw this because you had a
whole con uh uh confrontation with the
host dude that did it and I was like
what the [__] are you doing like don't
you know what the [__] you're doing like
I was upset because my friend
did the blunt my buddy provided the weed
and it was supposed to be a smokable
blunt I've lit I've lit hundreds of
these blunts no I remember the rocket
launcher you guys smoked hundreds
[__] RPG rockets
and at the end there's a big tip and you
I've smoked hundreds maybe thousands of
these blunts dude like I've hit them
past them they've lasted for hours this
guitar was supposed to last he threw it
I was upset
I said something
I mentioned it on my show
they didn't like what I had to say so
they saw your show and went I mean
someone told them or someone tagged me
you know there's a lot of snitches
basically you basically said that was
stupid yeah why did you guys do that
yeah and they got upset yeah was it a
full-on aggressive ass rant or oh for
sure
I mean it's just kind of like this I was
like yo my friend spent so much time
making it it was weed it's supposed to
last like that's some amateur [__] like
you know should have threw the crowd for
sure shouldn't have thrown it lit like I
know you're a rock star you have this
like big bad personality but like well
that's just a bad decision also a waste
of weed also like you got a bunch like
that's a lot of weed if I was on a week
yo you just wasted all that like yo you
should bust it yeah a bunch of [__]
blunts or joints or [__] bowls like
yeah it's horrible so you said something
look look I'm maybe that's why people
don't like me I'm real I'm Raw I let you
know how I feel I'm unedited that's you
know I do a lot of live streaming I
don't edit my [__] you get who I am I'm
the same person on line that I am in
real life there's a lot of people on
social media that aren't who they post
they are you know what I'm saying
there's a lot of people out there who
know who they post there I love it yeah
they are who they like you'll see in my
life like oh this person's cool whatever
like they're bye-bye and then you meet
him in real life and you're like where
is where is this person bro and then
like you'll maybe you'll do content with
them because like all right we'll try
some [__] and you understand like
my shit's usually one take I'm wrong
like natural this is what you get like a
lot of people have to like do it over
and over and over even though it's like
the same [__] I don't know what it is if
a hair is misplaced or I don't know what
but I'm just like yo you know what yeah
you know who you post you are I'm cool I
appreciate you but I'm out I'm out dude
so
so when do they approach you and let you
know that they saw the show uh they got
my phone number you [__] kidding me
called me threaten me
and then oh this got a lot deeper than I
thought it was gonna be I just asked our
booking manager about yo book Action
Bronson no you can't no I'm not that
it's like yo you can't get mad at me
I'm kidding I mean we're catching those
[__] basketballs whatever dude like
there was something expectations there
were other altercations that happened
after Michael got so mad he called you
yeah
yeah dude trying to like intimidate me
and then like I let someone know like oh
you shouldn't [__] with them they're
[__] blah blah blah blah I was like
bro like I'm not a friend and like if I
pull up to an event and they're there
like what the [__] and I mean [__]
happened at an event that I went to I
mean I don't want to talk a lot like
more into it but like some [__] happened
I'm like bro what the [__] that's why at
the house he acted the way he did
I saw it I mean all of that and I just
went huh yeah I wonder if they know each
other and I just kept getting high but
it's just crazy how and like what's
crazy to me is like that concept that
show that he had was basically my show
on be real TV
I'm not going to get too into it that
show that the guy that made up that show
that show on Vice guy that made up that
show there's a little piece of [__] I
used to work with
yeah that show dude yeah oh [__] that
show was basically my show on b-roll TV
I was supposed to have a show of advice
me and uh I didn't do it because of that
little [__] I was like out of respect
you used to work for me you don't like
him anymore I won't do it I got
approached I did a couple things but
they ended up like not doing [__] either
because I guess bad vibes whatever it is
get the [__] out of here I didn't know
it was that big of a deal I only asked I
was like yeah like what happened
oh but yeah so it's not it's his homies
you're talking about I know who you're
talking about yeah I have no beef but I
only saw I was actually trying to throw
a ball you went
awesome
sorry sorry I didn't know that was gonna
happen uh no we're good but we're
talking yeah
I'm still on the I'm still a fan I still
got the albums yeah that's good I'm
sorry I know we're friends but I didn't
know all I'm not mad
so uh let's get off topic of you [__]
people with rappers
and on to the next topic yeah hold on on
the next topic of yo this thing happened
with you and another rapper so I wanted
to bring up yeah so one day
Marty and I what were we doing when we
saw this video
I can't we were in the warehouse and I
went
what did Adam do
what did he do to make this man so
bad oh my God I know where we're going
oh I hope you know we're going Russ
yo so I let me just let me just uh give
a little backstory I'm on my phone and I
see your page and I see you post
certain video
talking about a rapper that is eight
feet from you
and you're like yeah so I'm not allowed
to go in this event because this feels
[__] scared or something I'm like yo
what Adam you button pushing
[__] what do you mean hold on
I'm in the next part of the video is
he's
walking away all arrogant [__]
look at his face look at his face
interpretation of what happened that's
exactly yeah what's happening yeah it is
as he's walking I just see the said
rapper
behind Adam like a shark coming at his
ass and I see like a security guard just
stop him so why does the exhibit like
you
yeah that's what you're trying to get I
know it's another question yo
that's okay it's okay it's all right why
the [__] ask him pit my ride wanted to
y'all stop stop it
look this is what I know I'll give you
my side of the story because this man
came at you and his security guard
stopped him from doing look there's
three sides to every story on anything
in life everything I say everyone else
will see so this is your logical person
this is what happened
even your brass knuckles yeah so I'll
get to it right now dude so I'll get to
it so I was uh working with brass
knuckles when they first started right
uh they hired me to do everything you
know I was like the face of brass
knuckles what is brass knuckles and they
were like one of the biggest yeah so one
booth they had three stories tall with a
strip club in it yeah
yeah yeah yeah we had a lot of crazy
parties and events that's the kind of
level they're like no no dude they
elevated the [__] yeah three stories
Like Water World City they built this
metal giant building
yeah the strip club in it it was like a
three trailers a trade show booth like
the hottestines event he was the face of
the [__] brand yeah okay you gotta
remember it's never gonna happen like
that again this will never happen again
another thing will ever be as dope so
it's kind of weird thinking about like
that was just live like damn that's a
goddamn Pioneer in the show truly if you
wanted to help you find all these
[__] pictures
of pioneers though but it's all good
with everyone they don't remember the
person who paved the road they remember
everyone after that yeah it's okay so uh
so I was doing breasts that were like I
was working with brass knuckles for a
little bit helping them with branding
promotions
wearing their merch when I host stage
whatever helping them out with marketing
right what they hired me to do uh I
started when I left be real TV we
started were you over at brass knuckles
TV when I did it did you come to an
episode I had to have because it was a
stupid dumb dope stage right it was like
a studio production yeah like camera
like like three teleprompters yeah I
guess he was like three Reds we had
teleprompter we had them there I don't
remember what it was but I did something
I think we did I did segments I had like
Purdue segments I had like it was live I
had the director like all that [__] so
you came back in the valley insane so
after b-real TV we like elevated our
content with brass knuckles with for
marketing and promotions and we did a
show dude I did like two seasons I had
like a little pump and smoke purple
that's right Blake Weber and [__] um
that's right Steph from uh Deftones that
Stephen Carpenter I met that man while
golfing and I didn't know yeah he was
until after I had like like it's just
High talking this queen yeah like
elevated the guest elevated the
Productions had like segments offset
onset like we had a whole show produced
that we were pitching to like networks
like we made
a show for networks to pick up like
elevated the content
um did like two seasons then do you
remember the whole brass knuckles
controversy I have no idea what happened
uh so remember when all the car you
remember the cartridge controversy when
everyone started like getting sick from
cartridge vitamin E and [__] everyone
started getting like uh uh testing for
like Eagle like pesticides were found in
there yeah there was like all sorts of
people started testing carts and finding
out how dirty they were and
unfortunately brass knuckles who was
like one of the biggest brands uh was on
that list and they ended up like how do
I miss all this
because you don't follow any pages and I
don't pay attention I think you just
follow my friends sorry so what happens
so and they were like the biggest brand
and they started getting a lot of like
[__] [__] like we do I mean you deal
with it daily I deal with it we get a
lot of haters in our comments whatever
we deal with it
um so they started getting all that [__]
and then remember after that all the
fake packaging started coming out
I know I've seen I've seen about 50 000
brass knuckle fake cartridges sold in my
face yeah yeah so so there oh well not
brass knuckles in like a general like
just brass knuckles I I understand what
hard plastic cases they're very heavy
but and and generally speaking like
people started making fake labels like
you go to downtown right now and you go
to a store you have your label down
there
they did do they still do it I don't
know how relevant my brand is I see when
you know when your [__] was outside they
had fake cards they had fake Edibles
yeah there was some [__] but
whatever dude it's it's it's like it's
like Bittersweet like if there's if
there is bootleg [__] of you it's like
Bittersweet yeah you're like you're like
one you're like [__] you I don't know
what this is I don't know what you're
representing anyone sick from this
product I don't even know if it's
quality I'm not even [__] profiting
off these lies like you're not even
chipping me down like it's [__] but
at the same time you're like I'm
relevant enough for people to understand
my branding and would want to
counterfeit it to push their fake [__]
so you're like I'm I'm cool but it's
[__] [__] of course so yeah it's
[__] up so people started bootlegging
there [__] then
um
I I was basically blamed for bringing
too much attention to the brand during
this whole controversy wait but you were
still repping them at the time well I
was just trying to like you know help
them out and be like yo it's maybe it
was a bootleg car you don't know what
they're testing people could just say
they're testing so you're backing them
up I was like you know I'm team brass
knuckles dude but
I got blamed for bringing too much
attention to the brand
but that's what they paid you for
oh okay
okay yes
if you didn't if you're just listening
to this I just threw my hands in the air
yes
so like okay but I so like then after
all that you know it's kind of dissolved
so though they got mad at you and said
you're bringing too much attention
you're fired no no no no no no no no no
no no
after all that [__] happened with the
whole pesticides on the parts and
everything uh I just decided to just
step away from all distillate that was
like the last thing I did with
distillate it was like
2017-18 whatever it was and I was like
you know what because of this I didn't
know you know I'm with one of the
biggest brands and this [__] happened to
them yeah I don't know whereas people
are sourcing shakes from people are
starting to meme me as like pesticide
King I'm like Eagle 20 man all of a
sudden and like I'm taking all the [__]
for it and then I'm getting blamed for
bringing attention to you I'm gonna step
away from you guys completely [__] off
you know what I appreciate the
opportunity we had fun we made great
content I wish I could get that content
because that little pump interview had
like over a million views on it on
YouTube I had these great moments that
are all gone they delete everything I
stepped away and I thought it was
whatever dude I was very cordial I seen
you know people from there since then
it's been cool
I think it's been wait that's your
[__] event yeah dude that's what I'm
saying I'm so cool with
I'm a very friendly dude I'm not very
confrontational I'm very open I work
with a lot of people like I like to see
people succeed so things were cool
um this one moment you're talking about
so I that they happen since then
no it's that was like three four years
ago you guys broke off yeah I mean I've
seen whatever random spots but there's
never been anything you know what I'm
saying so you never got into it with the
exhibit in any way shape or form never
you pulled up there with [__] shovel
yes that was the whole thing and he
acted like that towards you you guys
haven't even in front of everybody and
you haven't even talked no I like I
might have seen I think back the little
arrogant smile [__] I thought some
[__] happened like ow he won't let
me in the event look at this no dude you
haven't talked to him in that long no
what the [__] why was he mad at you
tell me I thought you knew why he was
nah dude so like I pull up with shavo
the nicest person ever the most genuine
dude if anyone wants any celebrity
branded weed go to 22 red wedding
because he really cares about his brand
and his product there's a lot of
celebrities out there look I appreciate
everyone's Hustle but chavo's unreal
smoker he's been smoking he's passionate
about this [__] get that twin if you see
a 22 red in the store and you're
wondering what to get Mr Jack is fire I
would say I would I would be
I would I would say get some [__] 22
red first celebrity weed yeah
not even just weeds me up dude like he's
like yo I'm going to San Diego I'm doing
the story hit me up too so Adam's coming
with me I go [__] I gotta film
tomorrow yeah so like I had a friend
with me yeah I had a free day I was like
yeah dude like I was supposed to go with
you shavo hits you up to [__] hang
out and rub like what like this is go
like Shadow is a dopest dude I'm honored
that he's inviting me so I'm like yo and
then like when I pull up to his house
that morning like I don't know what it
is I was like yo I got this thing pull
up with me I was like yeah I'll [__]
ride with you I want to go to his house
because it's gated and I love that
neighborhood I want to check out the
area we used to do I never mind uh I'll
tell you later uh just remind me about
this one way I'll tell you later about
that neighborhood
um
so I meet up Chavo at his house I pull
up and I look at the event I was like oh
um is it gonna be okay that I roll like
it's cool though I don't mind he's like
what do you mean I'm like oh this Fool's
here dude like Alvin's going oh so you
knew he was still mad at you no I just
said it because I knew like he just
never had good energy with me I told you
like I've seen him at events I've seen
him places it was just like did he say
hi no no he was just like like very cold
with me and [__] so you know you could
feel that way though
kind of like [__] played right now
I'm cool dude like you I don't see you
in the what did you do
that's what's kind of upsetting me right
now because it's like what the [__] did
you do that's where I've been that's
what I'm I thought that little smile man
ah I talked to you last time I can't
come back no no that's what I thought
that smile was but I know like all the
owners of the store like you know they
were excited that I was coming too and
[__] that's what I'm saying like here's
a Friendly's thing it's a friendly place
it's a weed shop so I pull up with shavo
in his car we're having a good time the
whole time we're talking vibing talking
music you know how shallow is with
conversation dude it's easy I'm sure you
had like a 12-hour podcast with him and
[__] but yeah
so I pull up
with shavo I'm cool dude I'm to myself I
I step back because travel pulls up so
everyone starts drawing to shops all
right so then I I just step away I know
my place I step away from the scene I
like just step back I'm just doing my
thing like whatever like people like hey
what's up Adam like yeah what's up guys
whatever shovel do anything and then I'm
sitting there
and then Alvin walks by
Alvin this exhibit's name yeah okay like
who the [__] talking about keep going
and he goes and I'm just sitting there
just finding my [__] you know whatever
arrogant smile regular smile I'm just
happy to be outside of this shop though
I was right outside the weed shop we
just pulled over in the parking lot
there's it's right there empty cameras
there's owners there's fans there's cars
like we I just pulled up with Chavo the
other main guest of us yeah exactly so
like everyone's looking at shovel now
you know his car is [__] super flashy
he's outside Studio Motors yeah yeah
yeah get them pleased who please if you
get us all right let's go no it's our
homies oh what I did my car what's up
they want to do another Benz the ones
that did my car yeah I meant to travel
yeah yeah what so I pull up this is I
don't think I've really said the story
dude so it's I don't know I don't
remember if I did or not but I haven't
heard because I just saw the video I'm
not one going around to gossip and I
don't want to talk [__] but again for
anyone out there it's like yo exhibit
look at this
friends never even asked I didn't even
ask
because we're not just sitting here
gossiping we're I'm asking yeah what's
going on I just want to know what
happened and I mean people ask this time
all the time so so basically I just
pulled up with shavo I mean you could
get any side of the story you want this
is how I seen it
I'm sitting there he walks by and says
do we have a problem to me and I'm like
no we don't have a problem do you have a
problem and he gets in my face
like and he's like trying to intimidate
me like x he's like yeah he's like dwell
is there gonna be a [__] problem like
starting yelling at me and I'm laughing
dude I'm not like intimidated I'm not
scared in my head I'm like dude if
you're gonna hit me just do it now while
all these cameras are watching please
like that's random like I'm just
I said obviously you have a problem dude
like what's the issue I wouldn't be like
what did I do I what's the issue I asked
him what oh you did ask yeah and he's
like in my face and I'm like look I'm
not I'm not a confrontational dude I'm
like dude what's the issue like
obviously you have a problem what's the
issue and I'm not like backing down I'm
not like trying to like back away I'm
like What's the [__] problem dude
like you obviously have an issue I'm
living rent free what's up
and then all of a sudden security comes
between us
and they're like oh and he's like get
this guy out of here he's he's not here
and I'm like me you're me dude you're
the aggressor like and Security's like
yo you need to go I'm like yo this is
the full threatening me and being
violent and you want me to leave so oh
and then like I'm looking at the owners
and they're like what the [__] and
chavo's over there like oh I can't
believe that's how bad he felt oh
luckily my boy our boy was there luckily
[__] Darby Darby pulled up
he was there Darby Darby Darby for real
yeah I didn't know he was there yeah so
he was there because of San Diego it's
[__] of course why would he be there
so I was like yo I'm pulling up like
pull up we're gonna do this [__] so the
nicest man ever brought you and he's
just like my friend and my other friend
I know how he feels so security was like
telling me I gotta go so I'm entertained
by this [__] that's when you recorded no
not yet oh not yet okay not yet so I'm
laughing and
she cares like you got to leave I'm like
you want me to leave and I'm looking at
everyone and the Chavo comes up he's
like bro what's going on I'm like I
don't know dude I told you like I told
you I don't know what the [__] I told
you if I should come like look what's
happening he's like bro what do we do
and I'm just like Bro [__] this and X is
trying to make a scene and I'm just like
bro this is stupid it's like you got to
leave I'm like all right bro look I
ain't here to [__] for this petty
[__] like I'm out and as I'm leaving
this is when I put on the [__] you
put your phone put my phone because if
it's mad that I'm here so I guess I
can't come in I'm Gonna Leave
I get why you were laughing now you're
like
the guy that we all loved as a kid is
trying to fight me
and you know more you were in his
company the thing I don't understand is
like I was like we know people that know
him obviously people are going to send
this to him yo that was kind of mean I
don't know what your what he thinks
maybe he has this whole perspective of
you for somebody else like you know
Adam's the one that was making those
memes right because you never know maybe
he thinks you're a [__] straight
piece of [__] I'm sure dude you must
have got the wrong idea I was the one
getting meme though it was my face on
this [__] I did it I did all that it has
to be something because nobody's just
going to act like that's a nice person
you know what I mean I'm sure exhibit's
a logical guy that doesn't sound like
something got Mis miscommunication
because look if he's ever here and you
want to bring it up ask him because I
just don't understand like you wouldn't
tell me like yo so one time I was it was
kind of a dick but nothing of that
happened so I know I remember I've seen
him at company parties I've seen them at
events blowing my [__] minds just
like with everybody else that like you
know you know it like people be online
and they'll be in the comments like I
and you're like all right bro well I'm
gonna be at the next high time so I'll
see you keep that and then they see you
they're like hey what's up like yo
here's some free shatter like thank you
I just don't understand what I'm like
why such a mainstream artist would be so
rude maybe act like [__] on his product
because he has weed products right like
at some point maybe you said somebody
products yeah I'm sure no because you
would be like no one time I was on my
podcast I talked [__] about his Laffy
Taffy no I never said something I never
spoke about that so what happened so
what happened is
being a dick and talk [__] he said Adam
was being a piece of [__] because
there's no way that he would go like I
paid you for my company now I just don't
like it there's no way man that's why I
don't get it so we're here to say like
yo exhibit this [__] didn't say
anything I I'm over I don't care dude I
just had to ask but it was hilarious
because I'm like yo what did you do to
get yeah you were expecting like a
devious story or something yes
company too
I thought you were part of it got to be
honest no I mean I thought you know I
was taking really good care of me you
know I thought you were part owner
because you were going well the thing is
that's the that like a lot of people
think that's the whole brand I work with
is because you don't own them but I'm
just very loyal to whoever I'm with and
I will [__] put it in and use my
platform my network to help your brand
and that's why you want to work with me
obviously so when you [__] play me
for doing something you wanted me to do
is just made me confused so you walk off
because of that I don't [__] with
distillate anymore but you walked off
and this full [__] straight he was
coming after you bro oh yeah you know
that right no I saw he was about to go I
should have kept on rolling he was about
to hook you in the back of the head he
was coming for it I just saw his face
went oh oh you know those those scenes
in uh when divers are going down
exploring and they have to replay it and
go if you look a shark was almost about
time yeah but luckily our camera light
scared it up yo it was like that like oh
look again oh [__] he's coming for him
like yeah but I wonder if I still have
another video security guard stopped
exhibit for making a bad mistake because
that would have been mean especially
afterwards and it wakes up and going bro
I never even did it I was that would
have been worse
what he was he was gonna hit you for
sure because you were recording him as
you were walking away your own face but
he's thinking you're recording him I
would I get it I get why he was gonna
snake you I would have for sure got the
house
[Laughter]
what assault what yeah but either way I
had to ask I thought it was way more
devious this Action Bronson thing was
way worse than I thought it was [__] I
had these notes I thought they were
gonna be fun funny stories and they
didn't turn up no the real story I'm a
real person dude no but they turned out
to be so much worse than I thought I
don't know if it's bad
it makes me wonder dude because I've
done like so much for these Brands and
these companies and like I was like like
you were saying dude like I was a
Pioneer on putting this content out
they're like I've been through multiple
YouTube accounts I've been through
multiple [__] Instagram accounts you
know I've had all the [__] violations
on every platform I'm on because
cannabis is so new and they don't know
how to regulate it and then you get
people that are just mad at what you've
done or who you are they think they just
want to be where you're at and they just
don't know how to express they just
don't know how to turn that into
motivation and they turn it into like
aggression because they don't they never
got that love growing up they didn't get
support a lot of people were grew up
without like you know
it's hard to say but in the states it's
been hard for families to [__] you
know make some [__] happen and you know
parents are always working they're not
showing a lot of affection to their kids
kids grow up with TV and [__]
internet and they just want to express
negativity instead of positivity and
your Vibe attracts your tribe so the
more angry and negative you are the more
of that you're going to attract to you
and you're always going to be depressed
so I just like look at it see it laugh
side step [__] move on and keep
pushing because life ain't gonna stop I
ain't gonna [__] dwell on this petty
ass [__] just travel some [__]
jumps that was great that was another
bumper sticker man I love that this is
this is real life dude like you know
it's crazy now because you know you've
been so consistent at what you've been
doing being on YouTube for about a
decade I've just been like
hopping around with content trying to
have all these ideas I have multiple
shows out there on with different
production companies I stream on Twitch
every [__] day now I'm like yeah so
what hold on real quick tell us about
your Twitch uh twitch because Rosie was
telling me like yo no I saw this [__]
Danny posted and I don't watch Twitch
because if I did I would be [__]
using it I don't have the time yeah
you're the first person to tell me like
Twitches where you need to be so like
two years ago you were telling me this
so during quarantine like I really got
involved during quarantine because a lot
of what I did was events and meetings
and going out and about and when this
covet [__] happened and we had
quarantine like all that [__] stopped
for me that was like 70 of my income
dude oh [__] so like I'm like what the
[__] so I started doing like IG lives
and giving out money and [__] doing
games on IG live just trying to have
events happening and then like I had a
couple friends on Twitch and I've been
they were telling me about twitch for a
couple years but to me Twitch was just
gaming like that was a platform for
people to watch people play video games
but they have a new category called just
chatting where
it's just you hanging out and you just
chat and you can do whatever you want so
during quarantine I pulled out my
[__] laptop and I [__] got twitch
created my account and [__] started
live streaming and since I'm in a legal
state where consumption is allowed I
don't violate terms and twitch allows it
so I sit there and we sesh I show them
what I'm smoking we watch random Youtube
videos we play [__] random web-based
games that everyone can participate a
lot of [__] but what I have a lot of
different categories of stuff you do
yeah I'm a variety show I go on Google
Earth I find weird [__] on our planet I
do conspiracy shows but what I started
in 2022 is I'm doing this hundred minute
hundred day challenges getting fit
ripped uh it's getting because I should
be getting high width but whatever so I
did a getting fit with where or getting
ripped with where I do exercises while
getting high so what I started doing is
live streaming me doing YouTube video
exercises and having people join me to
do it because I know people will be
sitting at their desk all day or laying
in bed or on the couch and like you
could sit down and just do arm circles
while you're [__] yeah getting
movement in doing motions dude
exactly you know what I'm saying morning
exercise I'm smoking weed while I do it
I'm taking dabs I'm [__] watching
videos we're doing Zumba dance routines
and I'm just a [__] average ass fat
Stoner dude I'm gluttonous with my
Munchies you know what I'm saying I
won't eat forever and won't stop because
I love [__] food and it makes me
happy so I don't like I don't count my
calories I don't see what I'm putting in
my body but I want to stay active so I
don't become like that stereotypical
unmotivated couch sitting [__] munchy
eating Stoner that they all portray us
as and as you were saying earlier I
don't really see it but you know a lot
of people say like I'm the face of
whatever this and representing this
industry I just don't want to be that
[__] stereotype so I started this
hundred minutes hundred day challenge
where I'm watching seven eight nine
YouTube workout videos 10 20 30 minute
videos and I'm just [__] doing these
videos with them uh live on stream and I
have people that are actually saying
like they haven't worked out in like 20
years they haven't done any Motion in a
couple years and they're just chilling
at home doing [__] calf raises is our
[__] wrist twist their [__]
entertainment and then like by the way
man do some pushes with me if you want
to do some [__] you don't have to do it
but do one
to see if you still can and then they
get motivated and right now I'm on like
day I just started bro I just started I
don't know what day it is but it's like
the first week and I'm doing 100 days
bro good [__] on Twitter highest host
Christian
that they acknowledge what state he
lives in and like oh my god do it Jesus
Christ or YouTube thank you would be so
sick if you let us adults
talk
because we get demonetized age
restricted on some of us no our podcast
episodes are interested
if you don't show anything I used to
upload all my podcasts on YouTube you
were you I have an episode with you and
Rosie I think your first time both of
you got interviewed or some [__] like we
would refer that's the one I was talking
about I was like that's a radio show
yeah yeah but I uh like I used to upload
that [__] but it's just
like I don't know what it is about
YouTube like it's a main platform but it
just lacks like Soul yeah it's very true
which I feel has a lot of soul it's a
lot very personal that's why a lot of
people can't handle it because it's real
raw unedited uncut you get what I am you
get who I you get my essence you get the
true person that's why a lot of people
can't like don't last on it because you
start understanding they're not who they
really post they are you can't edit you
have to go in there like can you do two
hours not something
I do like four hours six hour streams
dude and I'm just like on Google Earth
looking at the planet just studying [__]
and like seeing how it is the people are
in the chat yeah we're chilling hanging
out like yeah bro I'm at school [__]
watching this guys
I've been watching [__] baking videos
asmrs like close up bacon like making
Korean street snacks and [__] it's
[__] so relaxing and amazing to watch
and we're just smoking and having
conversation it's a great community yeah
that's the best part it's your fan yeah
that you [__] with and [__] with you and
then you attach your Discord to it to go
even more in depth post pictures get to
know your viewers and you know it's very
fan engaging viewer engagement which is
sick
you don't do it is there ads running if
you sub to the channel you don't get ads
if you don't sub you get basically use
ad Revenue share with twitch they pay
six dollars a month or some [__]
subscribers they're five six dollars and
you don't get any commercials but if I
want to watch Adam and I'm not
subscribed I'll get a 30 second ad every
yeah you'll get 30 second ad but then I
also share that ad Revenue with twitch
which is Amazon which is Jeff Bezos so I
work with Jeff Bezos
Partners yeah as he likes that let's go
that's the one that got Jeff Bezos kind
of buff right now right yeah he's
watching my stream I'm going on this I'm
going on the [__] penis spaceship
next dude yo I mean
I would say the bald guy in the
dictionary it's too Dr Evil you seen the
Idiocracy
have I seen
Idiocracy that's like real life those
that we're living in it's like that's
like a pre-documentary of our future
it's Terry Crews is the president and he
was a wrestler bro rock is running for
presidency no he's not what Dwayne
Johnson win what wait can we talk about
this this will be out
no we can't talk okay never mind so The
Rock
Dwayne The Rock Johnson dude okay uh to
be president no yeah he said he's
running I don't know probably you know
he'd win in a heartbeat right 100
he is oppress is running rate vice
president is the English-speaking
Terminator and I say that because
Schwarzenegger is my favorite guy but
you can't understand him sometimes and
he was the governor of California
who's smoking the pot yeah but he's
great I [__] love it I love all
sports the movies are him him as
anything I don't give a [__] I love to
her man I love Armstrong
his beliefs are you like just persons
beliefs I don't know what he believes I
just know he's the [__] you know he
knocked up his babysitter and God of
course and one of us have [__] ethnic
all right what if Arnold Schwarzenegger
kind of looks a little like this and I
like that that's pretty cool man
um
articulate giant man that every dude
wants to be as big and if they don't
they love the rock I don't want to be as
big as him there's a lot of dudes that
are like yo six five driving yeah that's
most little dudes he's been the world
champion
but not even that it's like yo that's
the yeah yeah that's the coolest these
are
Arnold our [__] Sylvester Stallone
and Robert really mixed in together yeah
he's all of these guys we've ever grew
up but like real life actually the guy
that can speak though yeah but he's an
action hero yeah and also in real life
he wouldn't [__] you up yeah he [__]
people elbow your ass dog dude I was
just talking were we talking about
earlier about people's elbow how long it
would take we used to do that [__] have
you ever smelled what he was cooking
that's what we talked about earlier yeah
like yo this [__] I still I used
to go to every every time wrestling was
in LA dude I used to go I've never been
to wrestling you've never been alive big
[__] wrestling fan as a kid I got you
know if you're in the first five rows of
a wrestling pay-per-view you get to take
on the chairs I don't want to take
voluntary what you don't want a [__]
wrestling chair it has wrestling stuff
on it yeah it's the pay-per-view I have
like four of them dude damn it's the
pay-per-view it has their picture the
logo I don't know any wrestlers that are
still active I still want to go yeah I
don't know the story lines as much but a
lot I never cared about live events in
general even if you like if I go to a
live football game live baseball live
hockey whatever you go to a lot of
wrestling I know that I want to go I
used to go to a lot of a lot a lot of
live they were just here for Smackdown I
missed it yeah I'm down to check it out
I mean as long as as long as
everything's still safe and cool and
I've never been to the crypto.com arena
so I'm ready I've been a Staples Center
I saw that right yeah that's crazy
that's crazy the change the Staples
underneath yeah yeah it's not stable
first off Staples has really sell that
much paper
just selling some random companies
owning these [__] maybe that's why
they sold it because they're like yo
we're not doing that good yeah have you
seen any Staples lately I go to Staples
a lot I do but I have to do a lot of
office shows they're probably their [__]
probably went up during the pandemic
everybody buying home office supplies
for sure for sure I would think like
FedEx Kinkos would be better than like
people would go there more than FedEx
and Kinkos are hella whack are they I
don't [__] I don't know what about
Office Depot Office Depot is the Kmart
[Laughter]
kid goes is [__] awesome Kmart so
Staples is the one staples is okay the
mainstream I feel a new sponsorship
coming soon I don't know I just I use a
lot and there's one number said I used
to go to a lot they just got what was it
900 million or 700 million what'd they
get for that they're like Circuit City
like how the [__] are they still in
business online [__] I don't know maybe
maybe Supply offices but offices are
like obsolete almost because they just
Supply a straight Amazon [__] that's
like that's what Amazon specializes in
but if you don't want to wait for days
what about Uline like hey shout out to
you line uh I'm a prime premium Amazon
there but uline's still around and I'm
saying you line up in the top to
remember yeah I spent so much
[__] money with Uline last year
that my accountant went like yo spend
double we're knocking it right I have
everything in that [__] Warehouse as
you want every single you're out here
getting racks and everything all the
literal racks are all from [__] you
all right every bucket every [__]
thing every piece of tape shout out to
you [__] discount
you're like 60 bands with them last year
damn it's crazy just on uh oh shipping
[__] it's [__] amazing I love you one
let's go shout out to you line wow yo
what happened how did we get on this
topic uh for real I think can you bring
it back can you bring it back
I remember exhibit actually it was right
after this next part the office [__] not
before that oh I don't know the worst
part about this is we watch premieres so
I'm in the chat going oh that's what it
was
all right guys so I guess I'm hot no I
don't
so I'll be in the chat on Monday going
idiocracy president thank you thank you
it was idiocracy you ever seen the movie
idiots yes we're living in it yeah the
rock would win that's what we know how
we got to the office though from The
Rock I don't know but that's exactly
what would happen that's exactly what
happened Marty what are we at oh I know
how wow Staple Center Staples office
going to see live wrestling events
this whole city had a bad memory look at
this [__] go you bring it look that's
what his conversation brings that [__]
out you bring up [__] and then I'll
remember it that's the truth David but I
had some amazing live wrestling event
moments dude like live when I've gone
through these events because I've sit in
the first five rows so hackers can see
you I sat behind uh uh uh Stephanie
McMahon uh his family when she was
fighting uh I sat with next to Ronda
Rousey one year before she got involved
with wrestling when they were building
her storyline up I sat next to Fred
Durst and David Arquette one year and
then you [__] end up hanging out
later well I used to hang out with Sean
Kush she used to have the first medical
beach house on Venice Boulevard on
Venice boardwalk on Venice boardwalk
there used to be a hash lounge and you
could go in there and smoke weed this is
like 2009 10 11 and I used to do events
there dude I used to do podcast there we
used to host hash competitions so he was
into wrestling so I used to get tickets
with him first five rows because he knew
someone one year I wasn't really feeling
it so he had Randy Orton call me a dude
[__] wrestler Randy yeah the [__]
yeah yeah uh well Venom I forgot his
nickname dude this was so long ago but
Randy Orton hit me up like well you're
not coming I was like all right now I'm
definitely I guess
I was like the [__] Superstar he was
that's when he was like just starting
yeah whatever the [__] yeah that's all I
know about him at Batista so uh yeah it
was crazy like I've gotten high with a
couple of the wrestlers in real life I
don't want a name drop because I don't
know if they're in the contract but like
RVD for sure I've had pictures with him
but there's been other all right and
Godfather I've had pictures with him
he's like super involved but there's
other restaurants I've seen him in the
week in history a lot a lot a lot but
yeah I had a great time dude also Live
Events I know a lot of [__]
have commented this I don't know how I
didn't bring it up yet yes this is the
guy from The Two Chains [__] oh yeah
yeah all right so because that [__] has
a lot of [__] views and I know
there's a lot of people like this looks
just like the dude from the two chains
yo so
the most expensivest video ever right is
the one with you most expensivest uh
it's the most expensive is sesh uh shout
out to Dr Dina for getting me involved
at your event yeah the other day she
pulled out I was shocked that she pulled
up shout out to demon yeah yeah she's
been super safe but um so
uh
uh uh what was it oh the two chains
thing so um
the first did you see the first one that
they did so they did the first most
expensive [__] and they just ran into
like a random smoke shop and this full
pool like the super generic big glass
bong it was like eight feet not
functional it was kind of like a whack
and they showed like some weird [__]
like oh it's the most expensive is I'm
like bro can we show them like because
two chains used to go into her shop a
lot yeah I was like yo can we like do a
real episode like that's how this
actually represent the culture and like
show the actual real appreciation for
Glass artists and all this [__] so Dino
did what she did they did a second
episode she asked me to help her co-host
I got my boy uh Dave to help Supply a
lot of the glass and it was for G it was
before Vice picked it up it was GG yeah
it was a GQ episode and I was just there
you know doing my best to represent
our culture dude while all these
vultures are coming in and you know
there was it was a long time ago so like
dabbing was a little excessive but it
was cool you mean not like to dance
well we were dabbing and talking about
dabs hitting the dab and I was like bro
now that I watched it he's like looking
at it like uh she didn't age very well I
mean like it was fine I did it but it
was just like it was fine at the same
time I look back you know I'm sure you
look back at [__] you're like uh that's
it a little cringe I can't wait for all
like the little kids that were dabbing
to grow up and find out what it means
anyway
yeah with a torch on them
no but it was a great time I mean I have
a lot of people that pull up on my
twitch chat asking me if I'm that dude
or if I'm Russ and then I have a bunch
of uh people that just see me like oh
you're that dude from Two Chains yeah
dude shout out to Two Chains so where
can everybody find all your [__] on
Twitter it's
probably takes you there too uh highest
host Adam ill on Instagram I don't know
how long that's gonna last yeah I know I
know so I think it's getting high with
on Twitter what's your YouTube uh
YouTube is getting high with getting
high with yeah I think if you just type
in Adam ill it mostly I mean if your
Google search it type in Adam ill fishic
is deleted like mine dude yeah and I'm
just that tired of just like keeping it
up I try to keep my website up to date
shout out to my web dude um you know
they'd be doing a lot of work for us and
uh that's like what I've been doing guy
there's just it's crazy it's just crazy
to see what weed has come to and like
what's his culture has been and it's not
really a culture right now no it's just
like I said it's a circus bro
it's a circus dude but look there's no
Wii culture right now it's all gone I'm
trying to keep it when it comes to
hosting and it comes to people doing the
show that there's no one else I think of
there's no one else that's done the most
weed [__] in the possible it's possible
hosting [__] [__] being the face of
many you
know there's a lot of people who hosting
but they don't do it it's not the same I
mean I was very fortunate to meet the
late great Jack Herer hair jacket
however you guys want to say Jack hair
um when I was butt ending and he had a
very strong passion for the whole
cannabis plant and uh spreading the
message of the benefits and I've read
his book and meeting him was great and
uh he just kind of made me want to just
educate [__] on cannabis when
you say this more and I like to do it in
a way where it's not like I'm forcing
education and trying to teach you
something I'm trying to be entertaining
and hopefully you learned something from
that entertainment you're enjoying
instead of trying to force a lesson on
you hoping you get entertained I'd
rather you be entertained before you
learn something and I feel like you
learn a lot more when you're having a
good time Bill Nye the science so yeah
so bring in like lifestyle to podcasting
and telling people what to look for when
you buy weed or what the difference is
between BHO and rosin and resin and and
all the terpenes and all that [__] but
doing it as a consumer instead of a
[__] hey guys so this is what we're
gonna talk about terpenes today and well
anal does and better care of eveline and
[__] paintings no I'm just like yo
this is
what I'm talking this is how I feel and
can I just say something too while I'm
on this platform dude I hate when people
identify sativas and indicas as flowers
that treat them [__] high and low and
relaxed and creative because sativas and
indicas are described more as how the
plant grows rather than how the plant
makes you feel and I I've seen giving
people sativas that knock them out and
they don't know because they're just
saying that people say like oh this [__]
gets me real Creative Real head high
that's just real body sativas test a lot
higher than indicas usually they even
make my head feel weird well I'm gonna
give you some good service dude the
demons I smoke make my head feel like I
feel high up here instead of the body
drag what you don't like that [__] no
what I want to be doing this yeah yeah
but functioning I function and do it all
day I don't like the sativa head space
it gives me sometimes because I get
Spacey and I forget a few things and I
cannot stand for getting shot you
dropped the lighter right I don't know
if I dropped it I think I think so I
think yeah I think so sorry I got this
one back up we're professionals oh I
have one right [__] here
I wish I wish I had a Roger the machine
I'd make some blunt rosin right now for
you dude I gave it to my friend yeah
he's gonna do it anymore dude I'm trying
I'm driving by houses here in the
apartment I would like uh it's it's
eight at night
with the air compressor
full air compressor hooked up Jesus
pressing two Zips sometimes not the best
yeah getting three hits off two Zips I'm
like I should have just rolled that up
with a bunch of joints
it's great but look I've got rid of a
couple of my rosin presses too yeah I
just have one portable now I gave them
portable to my last friend yeah my last
one to my friends yeah yeah yeah oh what
time is it I'm trying to do like I'm a
[__] uh uh weed yard sale dude
that's a good idea what's up
you good
our friend just went to jail and even
call him damn I'm sorry I complete he
didn't call me either so maybe he was
busy uh go to the [__] jail he's no
he said he would call me before he went
in oh my friend had turned himself into
jail today don't know well if it's not
that bad he'll be out in the weekend no
he'll be gone for a while but well oh
I'm sorry I didn't I forgot I'm like yo
remember before Aaron gets here I said
in my head where I'm get you make sure
to call his ass I'm sorry I talked to
him this morning though so it's not like
it's a huge deal okay
[Music]
I'm sorry hopefully you're watching this
episode bro I remembered okay I
remembered you forgot to call me I'm
sorry dude be strong be safe you'll be
out soon it's La is he in L.A okay uh
he'll be out real soon yeah he'll be on
soon I mean LA's crazy right it's like
Gotham City out there bro it's like
Gotham
bro are you on citizen no do you have
the citizen app can't be I forgot no are
you guys familiar with the citizen app
you can hear what the [__] is going on
man you really know what happened the
citizen app is basically it tells you
all the crime going on around your house
all the police calls insane all the
[__] assaults all the [__] dude and
you know beat up every five minutes bro
there's fires people get stabbed all day
salts so in my neighborhood now dude
like it's happening regularly like when
I go to downtown it's like always going
off but in my neighborhood now it's like
home invasion [__] robbery at this
restaurant like you've seen the news
lately dude you can't even like eat at a
restaurant with a watch on
I'm so glad I don't like jewelry me too
with that [__] chain on listen uh me
too listen dude as I tuck this listen
this is for stages I rented it I read
today it's for stage dog that's the only
[__] I'd ever rocked I don't know if I
want to basic it but it's like I just
plain J Dude I like that if I'm not
trying to be super like flashy you know
that's the uh the only thing I'd ever
rocked though is it's one of those this
is a two I don't know what jewelry box
this is a Jewish special two for one a
Jewish
that's a jeweler that's a jeweler days
dude I have some homies that just put in
like a couple houses worth on a chain
yeah and then he went
man I had to put that [__] in the safe
all these fools started getting robbed
yeah he has security with him at [__]
dinner
Fools With Guns just because you can
rock your shoes I used to roll with
people that had their own private
security dog it's crazy it's crazy
car if you have fancy shoes if you have
like a watch like them eating them
checks ain't coming in anymore a lot of
people are desperate yeah it's [__]
crazy I mean I'm glad I isolate and stay
home and and live stream on Twitch my
car's fast trying to [__] get me in
my car yeah when you least expect this
when you're eating at a table with your
girl that's fine yeah exactly you want
my Nikes I mean you want my Vans yeah
exactly you really want these Vans you
have to unlace them they're high tops
you don't want these bands yeah exactly
but I get the car my car I get that but
also
there's a lot of [__] cars look on my
car I mean that's not a super flashy car
do you usually pass with your guests or
you guys usually no I don't pass no
joints do you pass still no just Rosie
and maybe Marty okay I don't really
smoke yeah you don't pass anything yeah
I haven't passed this like this
[__] you should do this Roll It
Go
that link is all blunt you don't want to
hit that event you don't want to hit
this I swear it's like the comedic way
of saying like I know but it was funny I
mean there's a lot of issues why I
didn't pass but yeah I wouldn't pass
[__] yeah I mean but you know I used to
host those events and like I'd be in
front of like hundreds and everyone
wants to smoke with me to pass my [__] I
have a blunt they want to hit it they
want me to smoke and I used to there
used to be a segment on my side I used
to do it too I used to let people hit it
and I call if you ever hear me call
Cannabis Cup it
me and Rosie want Cannabis Cup that [__]
yeah I always tell her it's this yeah
yeah you smell the joint like this you
smoke it with the filter almost to the
front or you even pocket it you put it
in your oh yeah like this
like this yeah right here between your
fingers hold your hand like this cup it
and go but I used to do this bit on
stage dude okay yeah that's that's a
safe way to get him to skip that [__]
but I should do this bit on stage where
I said
yeah get the Cannabis Cup dude Cannabis
Cup it dude
that's that airflow dude you got that
extra air with that okay right now a dry
Steamroller hit no that's what it was
yeah so uh I should do a segment on
stage where I used to say get me high
I'll hook you up because I used to have
all sorts of giveaways Edibles dabs and
[__] so I would take like a dab a hit
from a joint a bong hit from random
[__] right but this is before
and like you know we used to be communal
it used to be cool and then oh I get it
sometimes I would hit one I'd be like oh
what the [__] or I'd take a dab you're
like what the [__] did you give me dog
like it would be like horrible like fish
tasting dabs it'd be soggy ass joints
and I'd be like yo I just [__] made
out with everyone in this young Place
dude yep that's why I stopped hitting
the bunch you guys started doing the
sessions that's why I'm always first
let it go every time at the rainbow room
like nah let that one go yeah yeah now
let it go let it go I'm not hitting it
again
now you know you know just as well as I
do Cannabis Cup that [__] yeah but
there's a lot of issues with that too
like like not to [__] make a drastic
down talk but like HPV is real crazy out
here and that's one of the major ways of
getting it is like mouth to mouth saliva
and you doing communal [__] and hitting
it and having like 40 people hit that
[__] dude it gets kind of dangerous dude
so you got to just be careful with who
you're sharing and what you're hitting
it with for sure 100 it's scary I don't
pass [__] I don't I stop I've been like
I'm like five six years now no passing
thank you you want to hit this you sure
that [__]
oh someone's driving here in that [__]
wow loud
right they want to roll one up right now
oh my God I'm pretty high that's the
most weed i've smoked on the show what
yeah it's the most we haven't smoked any
joints no just I roll my own dude I know
but I rolled like a half ounce I'm
prepared
when do you feel bad they're all gone
I only have zip in like three four
joints but yeah I had like three four
blunts dude
Jesus Christ let's go all right I rolled
so much well we keep up dude look that
way it's boxed in here we go with the
lights up there yeah you get that all
the time too you get like oh can you
outspoke this person can you outspoke
that that's not really announcement it's
more of like all my lungs here I'm done
yeah yeah or it's like yeah we can't
it's not about smoking we could probably
go Toe to Toe and none of this will tap
out like I smoke all day every day dude
like it's just something I do so it's
not a competition I'm done with like
because there's certain people I see and
go I don't if there was a competition I
had to I don't want to go no I retired
no I retired no there's certain people I
see I go eight gram gold I'm good yeah
Dad Maniac [__] you're good dude let's
just do that goes to the events you used
to do no 33 gram dabs no [__] thank
you yeah and people would be taking like
red hot dabs like I used to do that I
took a two grand three gram dab in front
of me he's like I'll take a little three
grand would you just [__] say yeah
he'll Cho a three gram dab and he's
really like
he's not going but people will say that
about you now you just faced four joints
back to back up there's some people I
see I'm like yo what we don't want to
smoke with you I just faced multiple
blunts too dog like I know it's like
yeah
that's just weed in conversation and I'm
not sitting here hit it the whole time
like talking what's up how's it being a
gentleman
these are sipping joints you know yeah
um yeah so but yeah so hold on hold on
real quick
highest host on Twitch all the other
shit's [__] I I'm really focused on
Twitch right now that's like my
madameil.com yes or highest host.com
yeah yeah I should take you to like my
website all right adamale highest host
highest host Adam ill Adam ill so I'll
be joining Adam on one of these these
fit rip things very soon yeah dude I see
you got a gym I know I'm gonna join Adam
I think we're gonna do it here so I do
like why we could do exercises bro that
are real easy like I'm not an expert you
see me I'm just a regular ass dude and I
do some motions but I also incorporate
weed and dabs with my ass I'm down to
get high with it I'm saying like we are
weights down here we have everything
yeah so like I have these attachments
dude
so we talk about the clips right yeah
yeah I don't know if you've seen these
videos but like I can attach this to
like a dumbbell or like a band yeah and
then I clip my whatever joint you want
so as it's on and you do like a curl you
puff you know so your puffing curls
you're not like working out with weed
you're working out with weights but
getting high get I do like uh wall sit
dabs average [__] is going to
pass out wait you don't have to Puff
every time okay okay but like you have
to breathe because you're supposed to
breathe when you work down a lot of
people hold their breath this is the way
to put it if you hate working out but
you'll smoke a weed do this yeah and you
at least have to move if you wanted
nothing there it is there it is I don't
expect you to do the whole thing like I
don't know dude I just when I live
stream my exercises I can just go I went
for three hours today dude I did some
country line dance Zumba workout I did
some Latin La Chona [__] dance moves
I did something hit it exercise some hit
exercises we'd warm
they hate me already but it doesn't
matter though because I'm just [__]
out here trying to live my life I hate
me already I don't give a [__] I'm just
trying to adjust and adapt to [__] going
on I used to go to the gym but if I have
people now hitting me up like encourage
like they're they want to work out
they're not motivated and they're doing
exercises they're telling me like Oh my
legs are sore I'm like bro you barely
did like 10 squats but I'm glad you did
that because when was the last time you
did it and now you're [__] being
active again yeah and to me health is
wealth you know you can't enjoy life if
you're not healthy so being motivated
being active doing [__] and if I need
anything I can do with weed involved I'm
there dude and if I have this new
path to pave of getting fit ripped
because I know people smoke before
working out or were smoked after working
out but
I like doing it all throughout my
workout suit and I can make it happen
and do real exercises and let's do it I
just have the bong next to everything
look I could put this on the bench on
the [__] bar so every time you come
down I did a skit of this one time on
YouTube go check it out with weed this
was doing it for real real it was a
[__] joke and this was really
actually
so like yeah first time yeah 2015 is the
first time I did it's funny bro it is
real [__] truly like yo you're actually
doing it yo what we just got a couple
pre-rolls throw them in there but Jay
does that we'll just take dabs in the
middle since yeah that's so what I like
to do is do wall sits and dab while I do
a wall set I won't be doing that because
I like to like I like active rest you
know what I'm saying I like to rest but
I like to like active yeah I walk into a
circle yeah that's cool or like I'll
like lay down and do like [__] like
glute raises and [__] while I'm resting
or some [__] just random that's like
when you hump the air when you lay on
your back in like this little said
active rest you mean more workouts no
it's like it's like resting but you're
still like I move it I mean you don't
have to do it everything
bro like I wake up though I'm sure
people can relate I wake up sometimes
with like anxiety dude like you know
what it is with our lives like we don't
have regular income we work for our own
[__] we're not working for anybody we're
working either for ourselves or with
people so like I wake up wondering what
my next shit's gonna be what I'm gonna
do and you know that anxiety builds and
you got to find [__] you gotta
acknowledge what's going on I breathe
through it and working out kind of helps
me get through it and if it can help
other people with that [__] like yeah
they're on Twitch it's just throw it
away yeah if you see me doing [__]
jumping jacks all of a sudden cooking
join in oh you can't be either though
let's go I mean like schoolyard [__] I
[__] with them that's cool that's the
new [__] you're doing and everybody can
do it from home you don't have to go
nowhere I'm doing a 100 day challenge uh
look at before picture right now no I'm
just kidding another jean jacket
I try to do a hundred minutes uh for the
100 days which is like an hour 40 of
working out but it's like you know
working talking smoking and [__] so I
average about two and a half hours
because I do it like football like
soccer rules like taking out all the
time like talking like a lot of gags and
[__] so I like add a couple more minutes
to the work I do but I'm I'm being
active I'm on the first week in 2022 is
the year of [__] getting favorite dog
let's go I'll come here and do some
we'll do some exercises well the one you
do we'll do it here maybe we'll start a
fitness channel a fitness playlist on
your [__] page and we could do like
Stoner workouts a playlist what do you
mean Oh you mean like videos yeah like
you know how you have different
playlists you might have a [__]
whatever I don't know like a podcast
playlist
your videos let's do it again fit rip
videos so I also have a clean Channel
too we can actually just do workout
videos yeah we just don't know Fitness
style like with no I don't think this is
a category and we could just start to
think you all heard it look listen I
know there's a lot of women out there
trying to make [__] happen but you sound
like a [__] and please if you get
sick enough
side effects
you know you know how it is do people
see your [__] and then they do it and
then they claim their original and
you're like bro yeah also it's like all
right I did it first also it does do
better so I don't give a [__] yeah no
there's room for everybody look I'm not
mad but it's like if people talk [__]
like I mean the thing about yeah it's in
my notebook two years ago and I did it
two years ago yeah
and like there's room for everybody like
you could do your interpretation of it
because I know we all get motivated
inspired by other things but like when
you start blatantly copying and using
like catch phrases like if I see you
hosting events and you're on stage going
what I'm higher than you or you let's
get like bro like at least come up with
you I know I've had some people like
maybe still home yeah all these ideas
and colorways and fashion I know I don't
know if you spoke them about it but I
know about your whole [__] clothing
line controversy with that big company
oh you know what's going on for real
yeah behind you know I know dude so like
like there's a lot of [__] that we deal
with that like isn't beyond what we can
do and like we try to give everyone
watching like as much as we can but we
still don't want to like can't put
everything else [__] what our future up
so yeah like I know about that [__] so
there's
it's crazy dog it's a crazy world so you
know twitch has just been helping me out
a lot mentally and you know keeping me
occupied dog so drop themselves in the
middies baby for real not even that
[__] out there like look you
can do this [__] from your house yeah go
check it out well quarantine change that
for everybody I mean when you watch
basic TV like news people were doing
their new segments from their houses and
and like morning shows and talk shows
they were Zoom calling so it kind of
even the playing field for everybody
because now everyone's on the same level
it's just a matter of how you're
Distributing your content because and if
you have a personality I'd say this is
an early 2020 people personalities are
gonna [__] prosper and all the
[__] that were just
coasting off of having followers are
gonna like oh you have to be at home now
let's see if you're entertaining for
real and that's when should change you
notice there's a lot less content
creators right now right well yeah
they're also like deleting a lot of us
and [__] I'm not talking about weed
in general yeah when it comes to having
a personality [__] comedians doing
their own at-home sets yeah oh okay that
shit's tight the ones that actually give
a [__] will always rise you know what
I'm saying like you you've been I didn't
know you were doing radio for 10 years
yeah and they told you you know Taylor
Swift's in right now you're out well
yeah I mean you know the demographic is
crazy like the demographic changed like
by the way thanks for the 10 years you
should leave they didn't really fire me
either they're like we can't use you
right now so I was just like bro what so
I can't get unemployment but I'm not
fired but all right and then like but it
was it was a blessing
like I did my first weed event
competition called the bow Olympics BH
Olympics dude 2012 in a parking lot in
the valley where I had competitive
smoking game suit and I had like 12
sponsors and I was doing a parking lot
event [__] that I learned from the radio
station like I could turn parking lot
into a [__] eventually you use that
to do something that you've already I
learned which was weird yeah and I
turned my passion into a paycheck and
here it is my passion was Cannabis and
I'm like how can I monetize without
selling weed without like yeah and like
never being a sellout never trying to do
[__] like that and you know I was I'm
very more cautious with who I associate
with who I work with what I do because
you know your brand your reputation is
is what you got Doug that's true man and
there's not a lot of people that people
like yo so is there other influencer
people like it's not the same like I
make contacts by the way
I'm not trying to be an influencer I'm
out here that's what [__] will
put on the damn check yeah on the
[__] invoice like influencer I'm more
like marketing yeah advertising [__]
content I'm saying I'm in that category
you're on the verge on a different thing
it's not
the same for you because well you're
like hosting events and doing real [__]
yeah
promotions yeah Street marketing yeah it
turned into the Cannabis events yeah
just I just because it's a bigger
personality biggest hit in the world is
weed and the biggest thing was high
times and the person hosting all of it
was you yeah so when they come back and
think about and those [__] 10 years
from now I'm like oh yeah picture of
this fool with a [__] hat
doing this [__] wow you just do the same
picture the same dude a couple years now
that was like the look the [__] whole
thing that's what I'm saying like that's
what I think about so it's kind of wild
it's like now we're here we're not
really doing that [__] no more cause we
gotta evolve though I know it's weird
though isn't it I mean like how many
times uh Puff Daddy changed his name or
Sean did he agree whatever you say it's
odds like now we're just talking about
it like it was so long yeah because it
was [__] 20 years the dope is Yola
[__] ten years a decade dude I know I
was there with you from the beginning
right I have some [__] vintage
t-shirts I know I love that [__] I'll be
pulling them out and you're like what I
don't even remember I don't even have
those I don't have that one mine's all
[__] up now like I love this like
seven years old six years old
yeah I got the cement prints I got the
[__] air fresheners I got the old
school [__] prisms it's crazy it's crazy
to think about all those times all those
events every [__] event well I
remember I almost [__] killed you at
an event oh yeah before we get out of
here so at the Denver cup and he's like
I had to apologize to Thomas and I
looked at you before we get out of here
thank you for bringing that up before we
get out of here this is what the [__]
happened
you know shirt cannons you know you
shoot shirts out yeah boom every five
yards away yeah it's pretty strong yeah
some genius not Adam some [__] genius
Adam's hosting the [__] I shot the shot
again many times but I was against this
point right here okay I put many weed
and shatter and t-shirts and lanyards
and all that in there but
so this is what happened Marty's
changing this camera I'm gonna look at
this [__] camera
all right I'll look at all right so this
is what happened
I'm standing
and everybody that was not from Colorado
or California I gave a nug to I brought
two Zips of fire ass cookies like
stupid form cut cookies I brought two
Zips in my bag and I was just like yeah
like a stupid [__] crazy cookies was
exotic because now any of those dessert
strains are not here we're not talking
about the brand we're talking about the
actual talk about it the strain The
Strain yeah yeah any of those dessert
strains are not exotic I'm sorry oh gee
is exotic right now Haze is exotic green
wheat is exotic any weed that's fire to
right now it's exotic because it's
[__] foreign
I'm trying to make green weed great
again dude can we bring green weed back
like purples are good but I'm trying to
like get them I just want OG at all
times
oh my bad my bad so I'm standing there
giving a guy a nug
you know hey thanks so much man for
buying our [__] taking a picture Adam
stage is over this little section it's a
huge stage so I can see and hear you
this is where Rae Sremmurd performed yes
so we had a big space so many [__]
people it was unfucking this was your
first time it's like three 400 yards
away at the stage but I could see you
and there's that many people between us
that it doesn't feel 400 yards away
there's like thousands of people it was
so many people but I could see Adam's
stage
and they're
shooting shirt cans I'm like ah sick
and then out of nowhere
a piece of a [__] carb cap a carb cap
a glass carb cap
just shatters right in front of my booth
and hits a dude in the back of the leg
and he goes ah I think what the [__] was
that he looks at me and like dude what
was that and I look go did someone throw
a piece of glass at us
and I'm like that was stupid dicks
whoever threw that
I'm just going back to my thing I'm
[__] selling some shirt to some guy
and then a big glass [__] dab tool
shatters right in front of my booth and
hits me in the stomach like and it hits
me and I go
that was glass
they're shooting glass out of the
[__] shirt cannon and I went Rosie
watch the [__] Booth I was so Furious
because I was thinking if that hit me in
the face I'm gonna beat the [__]
everybody with the shirt cannon if they
hit anybody at first I didn't realize
that the guy in the leg got hit with a
shirt can because I'm like there's no
way anybody would shoot that someone
threw it and there's that many people I
thought you know people throw [__] in
crowds like dick heads they probably got
a free thing and just chucked it but
when I saw the direction of it I went oh
that came out of the [__] shirt can
on the other side because that had to
have been
and that's exactly what happened I saw
it again a shirt and then unwrapped was
a when hashes come in the glass jars
with its screw tops yes yeah the
see-through or the plastic hard plastic
see-through yeah yeah with the little
sticker yeah Vader ones and they went
and that's when I saw it like wow [__]
this and I walked to the side of the
[__] stage and I was like
I need to talk to whoever the [__]
shoot it and I was
yes and they're like oh oh I'm sorry I'm
like yo someone's shooting glass out of
[__] guns can you stop you shot me in
the [__] stomach you shot a guy in
the leg you're gonna have somebody in
the face and then I can't I don't
remember the Jaime I think his name was
I remember but he looked at me like
somebody put [__] there is glass in this
because he looked in was like there's
[__] glass dabbers and wrapped it was
wrapped up in the shirts yeah so when
they shot it they were assuming it all
stayed together but they flew out well
they tape it together tape it shut it
just opened and glass was shooting out
40 yards in the sky with power behind it
so that's the time I got really really
really upset and I never usually get
upset like that I'm sorry but I it
wasn't your fault but I remember I
yelled like what the [__] yeah [__]
pissed yeah but I remember when it hit
me in the direction it went and go yep
someone just shot this out at me so that
that's what we were talking about but
other than that nothing ever happened at
the events no they were usually good
they're really fun that's when I started
doing like eye contact and handing [__]
to people because people started
fighting for these giveaways like people
like starting rumbling I'm like people
fight like people were so aggressive I'm
like here there's enough for everybody
box over something free I've seen over a
lanyards each other I'm like bro it's a
lanyard like chill I was with I won't
say the company I was with the company
one time had like 10 pounds of weed I
think it's on my YouTube
and we just started throwing seal QPS
out in the crowd worst idea whatever I
kind of punched right in the [__]
I've I've seen that I felt so stupid
afterward I thought like
wait we threw three pounds full pounds
out
bad idea bro we threw a pound and then
15 hands just go and The Bash just the
bag just rips and the weed just goes to
weed showers dude has to do because
people are so inconsiderate and then
also what am I doing throwing three
bands in the crowd yeah maybe I should
have thought about it three bands a
piece but it's different it's different
back then it was a different time like
you said it's never going to be like
that again yeah but I did feel stupid
like yeah maybe I should have but at the
time you're just like yeah but at the
same time like we're throwing pounds
this is legendary [__] like I'm throwing
a football like throwing the pound like
a [__] football like I made like here
you go bars are sealed Square so I was
throwing like Frisbees and then you were
just watching
yup when you threw the first one and
everybody went oh they're really
throwing this [__] then everybody got
like aggressive [__] away yeah yeah dude
it was just pretty crazy I feel bad but
it's on my channel yeah that's crazy
dude
um so yeah before you guys had to say
that thank you for bringing that [__] up
I forgot
um I how long we've been here uh almost
three oh what stop it yeah yeah oh good
[__]
great [__] episode I thought it was
gonna be like an hour and a half maybe
two yeah did you ask all your questions
are we good dude yeah yeah all my
questions do you need to clean glass
thank you alcohol are you ready are you
ready actually here let me
give you yo so you know to clean
to clean your rigs I need this [__] like
it was a hard to find this [__]
called it ill call so yeah 99 ISO which
is very hard to find and then what's the
other one I added one percent clout in
there too 99 isopropyl alcohol one
percent yeah I do yeah yeah well so so
like this was funny though yes thank you
that's you know marketing
this is how I that's what I did dude so
like
everyone who smokes weeds especially out
of glass anyone who makes hash uh they
need alcohol
91 70 50 I was very fortunate enough to
have a
plug for alcohol someone hit me up like
yo I got a drum
what do you think I'm like all right
we'll call it alcohol I'll [__]
bottle it and I'll hook up my friends
and family because during this happened
during quarantine yeah right no one you
couldn't find it on the shelves all the
Lysol all the hand white all
disinfectant was gone the main
ingredient in that is isopropyl rubbing
alcohol and so I had a drum
sold the whole drum real quick because
all my homies were hitting me up
everyone has heady glass everyone be
dabbing the [__] gets dirty they need to
clean it
went and got another drum and I was
bottling it myself like stickering them
myself with that Avery [__] you know
at-home labels and [__] just super
computer generated [__]
sold that [__] quick did a little pop-up
shop uh did a little pop-up had people
meet me I was like all right enough
friends and family let me open it to the
public I had people meet me sold out
again I went to the factory got another
drum they're like what the [__] are you
doing with all this alcohol bro I was
like what do you mean dude it's alcohol
and I'm selling this [__] what alcohol
they're like where I'm like dude in L.A
like because shipping this is a hazard
yeah and it's expensive and I had
gallons I had 16 ounces I had 32 ounces
I had like all sorts of skews I was just
filling them up and just like hooking
people up selling it and [__] I needed
an income dog I need to adjust and adapt
this is my [__] Hustler mentality
like what can I do what's gonna happen
so then the factory my plugs like yo
we already have a shipping account
we have a [__] place where we could
fill up your bottles we could label them
for you it's going to cost you a little
bit more but you'll have them like this
stock branded labeled sell them pallets
and we'll ship them all across the
country you just tell us where and we'll
order so I [__] let people know and I
started [__] on my website just
shipping them all across the country and
then I got a distribution deal
and they started Distributing my alcohol
bro and it's just like branded it's
basically branded alcohol dude that's
very
comparable in price to all the other
products I just decided to Brand it
because all the [__] we buy is like CVS
Brands
yeah I have to buy alcohol dude it's an
ill Central item that smokers need and
and it's like the main ingredient for
hand sanitizer for cleaning so if you're
a germ freak and you want to like
disinfect your house you can just add
water to this you got any more I go full
I need them yeah dude at the store so
this is just something that as a real
smoker knowing that this is an essential
product which you know I usually I have
like Flavor I have like certain strains
I work with I have certain concentrates
because I know people will always
consume that [__] so I was like let me
make a product that I could put in
Target or I could put in CVS or I could
actually have in stores that aren't only
weed because you could go to a cigarette
shop you go to a head shop you could go
to the website and just order this and
make sure your glass is clean because
look because it's 99 bro if it's 99 I
can get a gallon I would buy every
[__] week well I needed everything
well if you're sponsored you know what
I'm saying if you had to have this I
went to the CVS yesterday couldn't find
it yeah so I have it all the time you go
to my website get it I have it at stores
I mean I don't know where your shop at
your hedge I don't know which head shops
you're at but let them know that you
need it and we'll hook you up dude like
look I wrote all this [__] dude I made
this [__] out here I was reading it all
right now dirty accessories that can
make you ill read it marketing
[__] yeah dude dirty accessories
bacteria and germs are all things that
can make you ill ill alcohol is an ideal
cleaning solution which prevents mildew
mold and stains while keeping your glass
looking new
like a lot of people don't change their
water and don't clean their glass and
that's right you can really really get
sick like mold bacteria like this [__]
is real that [__] grows in water I've
seen people smoke out of like looks like
coffee water out of their Rigs and not
only does it [__] up the flavor of the
weed it's also not healthy to get these
chemical compounds in your bronchial
sacs and now you're saturating your
lungs with whatever mysterious bacteria
is forming and then you get some weird
lung infection or breathing issues and
you don't know your weed could have PM
in it or mold a lot of people aren't
educated on this [__] and they're
smoking this letting it build up in the
water then they're getting sick so like
I'm always one to say change your water
even after you smoke like a couple bowls
like I would change that [__] too just
to like get to that get used to that
just put that in regular rotation every
other day yeah well it depends like is
it sitting out though I have a a dry
catch though yeah yeah so you have a
little filter it doesn't get all dirty
yet but they say well
ains and clean all that [__]
I'm excited because I [__] I am out
I'll hit 70. I saw a dog and you have to
use a lot more of that because it's not
because it works it doesn't [__] 30
water dude it doesn't work and it's
probably trash ass distillate water
that's trash
so in conclusion your dad made you like
want to sell everything on the planet
and do whatever you can and it turned
into an actual [__] profession yeah
dude I didn't want to pay for weed
anymore so I started selling weed
I was I was I I'm sure you had the same
story dude that's exactly where I
searched on the week yeah I mean I was
selling weed this whole time during this
whole story until like when I started
getting serious and right now I would
say until when 215 ended I like stopped
the whole trap [__] I was like I'm just
gonna be [__] work on this hosting
marketing I want to be like a legit
personality for the Cannabis I'm not
trying to trap anymore let me just see
if I could do this real [__] but like I
was that dude that bought an eighth from
my hook for my cousin sold three grams
to my homies
made some money off of it kept half a
gram smoked the weed with them
went back to my cousin
that [__] turns into getting an ounce
[__] turns into getting a quarter pound
I'm getting packs I'm now I'm going
above my cousin and meeting his plug the
grower getting this [__] now I'm a bud
tender so now I'm like legally trapping
this [__] I'm [__] 22 year old punk
in a Mercedes-Benz hardtop convertible
Rim just [__] making radio money
pouring [__] money trapping me [__]
like I'm like all right let's [__] do
this dude and it's just like sounds fun
it's been like a [__] road dog but I
just don't trap it anymore
I just don't travel anymore I mean you
it really I mean it really well that was
this conversation you're the one who
abducted by aliens and I spoke to half
zip today so yeah yeah
this conversation I was hooking up like
I was helping these ladies out dude like
they would come they're like yo I'm
about to do like a [__] anal gangbang
scene like I got some weed having we
Vicodin Norco Soma Xannies pain
relievers must so relaxers like they
needed that [__] and I was like
I mean it's the valley I mean it's
shaking and [__] backwards but this was
very a long long time ago Dude say it
back anyone hey baby oh man well
hopefully I'll be living there by the
end of the year anyway baby I'm uh is
that tatted on your finger yeah that's
what you're pointing at that's what
you're yeah all right all right we out
here for Life dude oh man this was fun
I'm never on this side bro I'm usually
way fun obviously there was so much
easier isn't it to be sitting there
going what do you want to know talk
about it
well I mean you know so much easier
going yeah stay on topic stay on point
okay I mean remember in the conversation
but you know what I'm saying as someone
that does it as a [__] profession
isn't it so much better yeah
[__] but
T oh damn you should hit the gym dog
[__] crap yeah man those bones would be
a lot stronger yeah
they would though
this has been a [__] exclusive asset
interview there's some things that we
were really talking about that we
brought up maybe rapper beef oh look
maybe I'm just a delicate dude from the
valley bro I just don't get it I have a
passion for me it could be a store name
just delicate dude from the valley bro
that's the name of a [__] culture
dude I love this that was great there's
a lot of bumper stickers you throughout
today
there's a lot today yeah dudes well man
thank you so much for being here I know
there's been some Legends in this chair
so I I'm honored that you asked me to be
on here of course man yeah learn look no
hate I got love for everybody if if take
anything away from me if you think so if
you think I [__] I'm mad at you I'm
not bro please it's all cool I have a
horrible memory so I don't even remember
the bad [__] that happened so so I love
I appreciate y'all thank y'all and uh
one more shout out for the Growers
please can we shout y'all out y'all keep
it up even though you get [__] floods
and bugs and mold and mildew and all
these obstacles and legalities and [__]
I appreciate y'all and the trimmers and
the [__] drivers and the bud tenders
and the Trappers and everyone involved
in a dog who get the wheat they're
mainly those girls yeah but the girl was
good the Growers make a lot more love
dude let's give them their flowers like
right now please
[Applause]
so what I'm gonna take away from this is
oh [__]
you do whatever you [__] want to do
honestly because you're growing up I had
to move back to Israel then I came back
started trapping it out and then I
worked in the morning and then I was
like no I'm gonna start this [__]
podcast after this radio [__] didn't go
south and it's just building a building
and building up from there I love it
yeah shout out to I love it man yeah
shout out to my boy Randy Wang and
[__] putting me in his living room
and telling me to talk about weed bro
it's like in making starting this [__]
dude yeah podcast turning into whatever
the [__] I do now love it man it's crazy
to think about we just talked about the
[__] we've done for the past decade yeah
because I've been doing the same [__]
you're at this you're the person that I
see at every [__] event but no matter
what since the late 1900s it's crazy
it's crazy to think about this man
that's what I've been doing since my
whole 20s yeah I mean I was just posting
videos on MySpace of me smoking weed
dude who knew that like Instagram yeah
and then it turned into Facebook and
then turned into Instagram and then
Snapchat and [__] Twitter social
media for [__] helping out yeah it
created a lot of new occupations for
people dude A lot of people are just my
whole life just getting paid
I mean and I wish it was fine I mean I
just want anyone to just you know if you
feel stuck and like you're not happy
just [__] transition and [__] do
something else yeah the point of life is
to just be happy dude like you can't
just live in anger and jealousy and envy
like social media is not real life dude
I'm telling you it's like a highlight
reel we all have obstacles life's like a
[__] roller coaster dude whatever you
see it's not all Glitz and glamor bro
we've all dealt with it we all have
those issues dude I wake up thinking of
[__] we have family issues there's
[__] all sorts of [__] that we deal
with bro so don't worry about the next
person just worry about you stay focused
and you know if you're [__] happy
then you're winning a life it's not all
about money dude it's not all about
money dude that's very true that's for
sure if I pay attention to what I do and
I'm like wait what happened to them
I was eight weeks ago like talking about
this made me realize and appreciate like
all the [__] that I've actually done and
have been a part of like if you talk
about La weed culture I feel like like I
am like that with all the events I've
done with all the products that's who I
think of yeah dude I mean there's not a
lot of people out there that actively
can actually hold a conversation and or
host something and or do content for
[__] 15 years yeah it's and there's
nobody that's done you know there's
nobody else think of this all organic
it's real [__] like I'm not out here
thinking or I don't have like a team I'm
not paying like
well writers the last one of the whole
Instagram I'm the last one still doing
[__] think about it yeah of all the
people that were doing Instagram content
like Neil me making [__] like you're
doing events and [__] I'm talking about
yeah making perfect yeah Tick Tock is
like a whole different thing the last
one yeah and you're the only one that
ever [__] was an actual host and did
[__] yeah that's all it took is like oh
this is what I do
there was no like there used to be 50 of
me's yeah making content
no there's a lot I'm not saying like me
[__] no I'm talking about content there
was people that did stuff like me yeah
content yeah and they're still out there
and they're like all new generations of
people and like content gets
regurgitated it's cool to see but it's
just not what it was just like this just
like the weed scene it's not what it was
people left that were doing what they
did when they said yeah and like my
thing is like I'm always trying to
transition adjust and adapt and what I
saw coming from radio and having
personalities and especially talk radio
is there was no like person in this
cannabis space like we had a jack who
was like the person that we knew but he
was like an activist we had Cheech and
Chong
we had like Snoop Dogg but he was a
rapper there was no like regular person
who was in it that was the that was like
represent and proud of being a consumer
everyone was in the closet and I felt
like there needed to be that person so
starting the podcast hosting these shows
getting the brands out there like it's
just there was no one I'm gonna host I
hosted events I hosted cups I hosted all
sorts of festivals and that's just like
what I'm doing now I got some shows that
are being well that are like produced
budget you came to my 420 special at
that one Studio dude yeah bro so like
that's what I would imagine hopefully
one day I can get this [__] place so
I mean you can make it we could talk
about that later yeah but we'll give you
that 250 bands yeah well I mean we don't
need that much but that [__] was like
but they've done [__] with like Disney
and Nickelodeon and all sorts I said I
don't know if you knew how much
expensive yeah
so I did like a live 420 stream on
Twitch dude and it was like I budget
dude like it was we put money into this
and this is like what I'm trying to do
with my content is Elevate the Cannabis
content because it's cool to be whatever
doing these little dances or smoking or
taking enormous dabs but like that's so
a decade ago like I'm trying to
represent and bring like new [__] like
we could incorporate weed into regular
[__] TV Concepts like I did a section
called the highest Shopping Network
where it was like my my [__]
appreciation towards 1900s infomercials
like when you used to watch it there was
a guy right there trying to sell you
products and telling you how great it
was and we did a little segment on this
420 show and I made that into an actual
full length feature where I was selling
products live on air taking in calls and
showing the benefits of these products
and it's like I'm just trying to like do
regular shows like I have a show called
hijinks which is basically like
Ridiculousness but with wheat smoking
and we watch viral videos and comment on
it that stage is [__] ridiculous yeah
have you been with it yet no uh what
stage itself
so the the 420 stream I did a five hour
live stream where I hit every 420 on
North America so I started with Canada's
420 which is 12 20 Pacific time and then
I hit East Coast Central mountain and
Pacific and I had segments lined up
props all sorts of [__] and um it was a
[__] it was crazy I was for the one I
was in one segment we did like eight
[__] we played Mario Kart 420 right
Mario Kart 6420
I didn't cheat I wouldn't you could play
to watch the video this [__]
knows cheats basically you we had smoked
we had a mean shot we looked at each
other
how's the small forward going so fast
I'm pressing down we head up here he
looked at you like [__]
Mario 6420 we had a pipe attached to the
next 64 controller and you had to finish
the Bowl before the race ended but you
couldn't smoke while driving because
that's illegal so you have to stop
driving in Smoke and then but you
finished the bowl and uh we raced and I
I won bro like I'm sorry and I won and
then we did a cooking segment where we
made some pizzas live and we did like a
like every category was different dude
thank you for coming I appreciate you
for being a part of that that [__]
stage but yeah so I'm just trying to be
like a host dude like a cannabis host
like a [__] Ryan wheat Crest or
whatever dude Ryan
well one day dude when this [__] gets
more mainstream there's not going to be
a lot of people to look to with the
experience and personality so I'm here
to keep doing your [__] Live status like
just keep doing your [__] exactly it's
America's Next pop model dude where you
at you do so many [__] festivals and
[__] like there's nobody else sees that
I appreciate you thank you for the words
I thank you I appreciate you man thank
you for coming on the show
thank you I can't believe that I was
trying to hit that 420 Mark no I'm just
playing oh don't do it no no I'm just
[__] with you like I said it's an
honor dude thank you for giving me your
time and letting me be in this legendary
chair and I'm glad to see all the
success you're getting dog keep killing
it keep it up
bro
all right yeah higher dude please yeah
hi with your family this year too
adamill.com all right go on Twitch
highest host yes highest host Marty got
anything Google Google this is a great
episode folks Marty looks highest I love
that all the time though no no it really
was this one man I hope you all learned
something about me
you'll look deeper than what you see on
social media and see who this [__]
delicate dude really is
fight him don't fight him
please all right guys thank you so much
for being here Adam thank you for being
here thank you guys thank you so much
this has been dope's usual podcast I'm
dope Zola yes have a dope ass day yo I
didn't realize you weren't gonna smoke
any of these joints I dusted them all
and then right when I was starting to
move right now should I ate more you
gotta go work out
oh you can
perfect
[Music]
thank you